Chaosradio Teil 125. Deja vu, die Musik kenn ich doch. Das Chaosradio Jingle, wie jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat auf Fritz. Klar, jetzt auch heute hier zu hören. Von 22 bis 1 Uhr, also jetzt mittlerweile knapp nach 22 Uhr und optimistisch gesehen 8 nach 10, aber die Zeit sei Paul van Dyck gegönnt. Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio Teil 125. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, ich grüße euch ganz herzlich. Wir reden wie immer im Chaosradio am Letzten Mittwoch auf Fritz über Dinge, die im weitesten Sinne mit digitaler Welt, mit Computern und sonstiger Technik zu tun haben. Zu Gast selbstverständlich der Chaos Computer Club, so auch heute, und zwar Annett Rebina, schönen guten Abend. Hallo. Und dann ist noch Thorsten Junge hier, hallo Thorsten. Und Frank Rosengart, hallo Frank. Hallo. Wir reden heute über Jugendschutz.
Oder Zensur.
Oder Zensur oder wir reden darüber, wie Altersfreigaben funktionieren. Wir reden darüber, dass ihr alle total gefährdet seid von der bösen, bösen, bösen Medienwelt da draußen, weil ihr ja Killerspiele spielt und weil ihr gewaltverherrlichende Musik hört und weil ihr gewaltverherrlichende Filme seht und weil sich niemand darum kümmert, dass ihr vor all diesen Bösartigkeiten geschützt werden müsst. Ganz jetzt im Speziellen auch sind viele, viele Politiker, besonders von der Union, wieder dabei zu sagen, das muss alles verboten werden, wir müssen das endlich verbieten, das ist alles ganz schlimm, die Jugend muss davor geschützt werden. Besonders jetzt ein halbes Jahr nach dem Armokloch von Emstetten, wo ja wieder mal eine große Welle der Entrüstung, selbstverständlich klar vor dieser Tat, aber natürlich auch vor sichigen Geschichten wie Computerspielen, Gewaltverherrlichenden, durch die Medien gingen und viele Politiker gesagt haben, sowas muss komplett verboten werden, der Jugendschutz muss verschärft werden, kann man jetzt sagen, halbes Jahr danach, wie sieht es denn aus mit dem verschärften Jugendschutz? Ich erinnere mich, dass wir vor einigen Monaten schon mal eine Sendung zum Thema hatten, wo ganz ganz viele von euch angerufen haben, unter 0331 77 97 110, das ist auch heute hoffentlich wieder der Fall, die sich zum Thema Killerspiele und Jugendschutz geäußert haben Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. Wir haben hier ein kleines Video von uns. In welchen Staffeln wird sowas gemacht? Was sind das für Leute, die diese Altersfreigabe machen? Was nützen die Verbote? Wer spricht die aus? Wie sollen die funktionieren? Was bringt es, wenn man die abschafft? Wenn man irgendwelche Dinge findet, wo man denkt, das ist jetzt vielleicht doch nicht so cool, so dass das vielleicht irgendwie mein elfjähriger Bruder sieht. Wo kann man sich denn beschweren? Speziell bei Webseiten, wenn man also eine Internetseite hat und sagt, die ist wahrscheinlich nicht für die Öffentlichkeit so zugänglich zu machen. Wem kann man denn sagen, ich hätte sowas gerne? Und da ich von solchen Dingen überhaupt keine Ahnung habe, freut mich sehr, dass der Chaos Computer Club heute Abend da ist, um eure Fragen zu diesem Thema zu klären. Und zwar unter 0331 70 97 110. Sind wir im Thema?
Interessant ist vielleicht auch, wenn ihr schon Eltern seid, wie geht ihr denn selbst damit um? Wenn ihr vielleicht noch nicht ganz so alte Eltern seid, wenn ihr zurückdenkt, wie war das bei euch und wie wollt ihr es jetzt gerne bei euren Kindern haben, das interessiert uns natürlich auch mal. Schließlich waren wir auch mal alle Kindern und haben Eltern gehabt, die uns was verboten haben. Und da waren wir vielleicht nicht so ganz einverstanden und wir wollten es dennoch wissen. Und wie geht ihr jetzt als Eltern möglicherweise dann damit um oder zumindest wenn ihr vielleicht demnächst Eltern seid, wie nehmt ihr euch vor, damit umzugehen?
Es gibt ja auch gerade diese Diskussion um eine Hip-Hop Combo aus Berlin. Das kann ich nicht wirklich nennen, auch aus Pietätsgründen sozusagen. Die haben ein Video ins Netz gestellt zu einem Song gerade aktuell und da haben sich Politiker drüber aufgeregt. Es geht da quasi um Gewaltausstachelung gegen Polizisten und die Politiker haben gesagt, so was geht nicht und das muss alles verboten werden und so weiter und so fort. Die Band kriegt dadurch eine Menge Presse, da kommt gerade ein aktuelles Album. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal so unbeabsichtigt, dass dann Silvesterknaller gezündet wird. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist dadurch natürlich auch die Diskussion wieder da. Nicht nur Computerspiele, sondern auch Videos und Musik und Filme und so weiter und so fort sollten verboten werden. Wir haben vorhin kurz vor der Sendung auch über Filme gesprochen. Thorsten ist ein großer Expert in Sachen Film und Fernsehen. Aktuelles Beispiel bei der Alterseinstufung war der letzte James Bond.
Genau, also James Bond war ja diesmal ab 12 freigegeben, was für James Bonds glaube ich relativ normal noch ist. Was natürlich schwierig war, war, dass dieser James Bond einfach mal anders war. Also wir hatten ja sozusagen die Neukreation dieser Reihe und die war auch vom Gewaltpotenzial ja einfach anders. Und es gibt seit kurzem diese neue Regelung Parental Guidance. Das heißt, du hast die Möglichkeit auch jüngere Kinder mitzunehmen, die jetzt unter 12 sind, wenn du halt der sogenannte Personensorger berechtigter bist, also Elternteil oder Stiefvater oder ähnliches. Und das ist natürlich auch die Frage, was weißt du als Elternteil vor über den Film?
Warte mal, Frank ist gerade gefallen, geht's dir gut?
Okay, das steht da schon wieder. Das wird dir auch wichtig. Mal die Frage, inwieweit kann man sich vorher informieren? Wie kann ich erfahren, was im Film wirklich geschieht? Weil ich weiß ja eigentlich nicht, was ich meinem Kind zumuten kann, wenn ich den Film nicht vorher sehe. Aber keiner guckt den Film vorher, um ihn dann noch mit dem Kind zu sehen.
Und auf was kann ich mich verlassen, wenn er drauf steht ab 12? Was bedeutet das im Speziellen?
Genau, das wird halt immer schwieriger. Weil du kannst es eben kaum noch wahrscheinlich.
Nicht, dass ihr glaubt, es wird jetzt hier so eine Sendung, wo wir die Zeigefinger erheben und zu sagen, böse, böse, böse, du, du, du, das ist alles verboten. Wir wollen nicht, dass ihr das guckt. Im Gegenteil, wir würden gerne mit euch darüber diskutieren, wie weit sollten Verbote gehen? Was geht gar nicht? Wo ist für euch die Grenze, wo ihr sagt, da sollte man vielleicht eine Art von Altersfreigabe geben? Und wie funktioniert denn der aktive Jugendschutz heutzutage? Was habt ihr dafür Erfahrung gemacht? Könnt ihr mit 14 in die Videothek gehen und euch ab 18 freigegebene Filme ausleihen, Actionfilme, was auch immer? Guckt da irgendjemand drauf? Gibt es Eltern, Großeltern, Enkel, Quatschblödsinn, Onkel, Tante, die sagen, wo du sagen kannst, zu Weihnachten hier, ich hätte gerne das und das Spiel und die gucken nicht drauf und bringen dir dann eben einfach mal was weiß ich, sag mir noch mal, ein aktuelles Ballerspiel, Doom 3, Manhunt ist gerade draußen, diese ganzen Geschichten, Max Payne und so, wo man relativ einfach...
Stalker ist jetzt auch glaube ich ziemlich neu.
Stalker, genau, Stalker ist auch ganz neu, wo man dann auch sagen kann, Jugendschutz in Deutschland hin und her, ist alles ganz prima, aber wenn die praktische Umsetzung nicht funktioniert, dann gibt es da irgendwann ein Problem. Und darüber würden wir gerne mit euch reden, oder auf Chaosradio.de, falls ihr telefonisch nicht durchkommt. Selbstverständlich, könnt ihr auch mailen. Und ansonsten würde ich sagen, fangen wir absolut provokativ an und hören sehr, sehr, sehr gefährliche, gewaltverherrlichende, jugendgefährdende Musik. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Ich hab schon mal einen. Bushido und Blumenau Fritz, wir reden heute über Jugendschutz, über Verbot von gewaltverherrlichenden oder jugendgefährdenden Medien-Ezeugnissen, sei es Musik, seien es Videos, seien es Internetseiten, seien es Filme, seien es Computerspiele. Wer sich von euch jetzt nach diesem Genuss des Songs von Bushido dazu bemüßigt fühlt, mit Drogen zu dealen oder sonstige krumme Geschichten zu machen, der hat nicht alle Latten am Zaun. 0331 70 97 110 ruft uns an, diskutiert mit uns darüber, wie der Jugendschutz in Deutschland funktioniert, welche Erfahrungen ihr gemacht habt und was ihr davon haltet. Guten Abend. Linus. Grüß dich. Du bist 12, damit quasi jemand, der an nichts rankommt. Naja, den neuen James Bond könntest du schon gucken, oder?
Ich komm an alles ran.
An alles?
Ich komm an alle Videos, an alle Musik und an alle Filme ran.
Und wie viel Mühe bereitet ihr das?
Wahrscheinlich, Linus klingt auch gerade so, als ob er sich nebenbei die Fußnägel feiern würde. Aber dass man das alles aus dem Netz saugen kann, darüber müssen wir nicht diskutieren. Über die Legalität und Illegalität dessen, das ist auch ein anderes Thema. Aber gibt es irgendjemand bei dir in der Familie, du wirst ja noch nicht alleine wohnen, der immer mal guckt und sagt, was machst du da eigentlich?
Meine Mutter, ich spreche mit ihr immer vorher ab, was ich spiele. Und wenn es halt okay ist, und da ich gerne Ballerspiele spiele, und so mein Lieblingsspiel ist ja GTA San Andreas.
Grand Theft Auto.
Genau. Ja, und das ist halt, das spiele ich halt nur bei Freunden, aber meine Mutter und ich haben uns auf Gojja geeinigt.
Aber ey, guck mal, am Rechner, sie rennt jetzt nicht oft durch irgendwelche alten Häuser und...
Und auch. Nein, ohne meine Mutter sind meine Kumpels.
Darf man mit 12 Stunden Gojja spielen, frage ich jetzt? Und wie kommst du dazu, Gojja zu spielen?
Also, an die Waffen kommt man in der Köln an Waffenläden von Türken und Arabern, die geben ein, das ist scheißegal.
Das heißt, du spielst Gojja privat organisiert, oder nicht irgendwo in einem Verein oder sowas?
Nee, nee, nee, ich spiel Gojja in alten Ruinen mit Kumpels.
Also ihr trefft euch einfach nachmittags, besorgt euch die Waffen und die...
Die haben wir alle hier.
Die habt ihr schon?
Moment, ganz kurz, Linus, ganz kurz, falls jetzt irgendjemand einschaltet, wir reden hier über ein Spiel, wo mit Luftdruck Pistolen Farbebeutel verschossen werden. Wenn ein Zwölfjähriger auf Fritz, Entschuldigung, wer ich jetzt sage, Linus, im Radio sagt, die Waffen haben wir alle hier, nicht dass jetzt irgendjemand da quasi nervös wird von der Polizei. Alles cool, alles cool, es ist eine Sportart. Und du kannst in Neukölln oder wo auch immer in den Laden gehen und sagen, ich hätte gerne da das und das Gerät. Und da kommt keiner und sagt, pass mal auf, du kannst doch nicht mal über meinen Dresen gucken, gibt's nicht. So viel zum Thema YouTube.
Hast du denn Lust zu Hause auch mal Ballerspiele zu spielen? Also ich mein, würdest du spielen, wenn es dir deine Eltern erlauben würden? Oder wär's dann vielleicht schon wieder langweilig?
Nee, ich würd's natürlich dann auch machen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich so da auch freuen würde, also ob mir so viel Spaß machen würde, wenn ich jeden Tag spielen kann.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, soll ich mit deinen Eltern zusammen zu spielen, oder wär dir das total zu blöd?
Mach ich manchmal. Also ich spiel keine Waderspiele mit denen, sondern ich spiel andere Spiele.
Klingt nach Kaugummi-Automat.
Ja, das ist so ein Spiel, da wirst du Bobbles verschieben und richtig gerein und sollt online gegeneinander spielen.
Welche Kategorie ist das von Computerspiel?
Klingt ein bisschen wie Tetris. Ja, ist klar, ist noch geiler als Tetris, weil Tetris ist ja 1985, aber so in der Art?
Nee, überhaupt nicht in der Art. Also, man muss drei reinkriegen und die halt immer verschieben zur Kuligrafik und sowas.
Alles klar. Bobbles wie die Blasen.
Ja, genau, und die muss man dann zum Platzen bringen.
Ah, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Ja, und also ich hör ja auch die Musik.
Warte mal, die Musik. Kannst du das mal ein bisschen präzisieren, Linus?
Okay, ich hör auch diese Gangster-Rap-Musik und diese gewaltverherrlichende Musik.
Diese gewaltverherrlichende Musik von Vans wie Silbermond, oder was?
Und warum? Weil es cool ist? Oder weil in deiner Clique die Leute das hören?
Na komm, tschuldigung, der Sonnenbank-Flavor-Beat ist der Hammer.
Ja, man muss ja irgendwie mit 12 Jahren dazukommen.
Also den find ich gar nicht gut, weil es irgendwie nur so ein Stichpunkt auf mir ist.
Ihr wollt doch nur ein bisschen provozieren, Linus.
Jedenfalls, na ja, eigentlich erstmal ist es innen. Und mir gefällt Musik eigentlich auch. Aber ich hör immer noch die Ärzte wie früher. Und ich hab mich da jetzt nicht einschränken lassen. Ich hör ihr alles querbeet.
Ich glaube, man muss auch, glaube ich, einen sehr großen Unterschied machen beim Thema, inwieweit stachelt Musik, Leute dazu auf, irgendwelche Dinge zu tun. Die Diskussion gab es bei Marilyn Manson, die Diskussion gab es bei Slipknot, die Diskussion gibt es bei Agro, und die Diskussion gibt es bei Bushido und bei allen anderen auch. Da muss man, glaube ich, sehr doll trennen. Und viele Leute, die nicht wissen, oder das gar nicht kennen und nur so Sachen nach erzählen, oder nur gehört haben, dass das total gewaltverherrlichend ist, machen sich natürlich einen großen Kopf. Also du bist nicht jemand, der jetzt eine Bushido-Platte hört und dann losrennt und Leuten aus dem Maul hauen will.
Nein, aber ich finde auch nicht, dass die ganze Diskussion so sinnlos ist. Weil es gibt zwei, drei Leute in Deutschland, die haben einfach eine Macke. Und die gibt es auch in jedem anderen Land. Und die können auch keine Ballerspiele spielen. Und die können auch keine gewaltverherrliche Musiks. Also zu sagen, die kriegen das einfach mit. Was so passiert, die sind ja nicht alle blöd. Dann machen sie es halt in der Realität. Weil die gucken mal einen Freund auf dem Bildschirm. Und die spielen das jetzt nicht selber stundenlang.
Da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht, dass Computerspiele mit Sicherheit kein auslösender Moment sind. Die sind ein kleiner Teil. Aber warum man Armok läuft oder durchknallt, da gehören viel zu viele andere Aspekte dazu. Da gehört vielleicht ein zerrüttetes Elternhaus, keine Akzeptanz in der Schule, Außenseiter sein. Eine ganze Palette gehört da glaube ich schon dazu.
Linus, glaubst du denn, dass diese Spiele bei allen unbedenklich sind? Oder jetzt vor allem nur bei dir und deinen Freunden? Also jetzt, dass sie keine Ausfuckungen haben. Du meinst, du bist weiterhin relativ entspannt und es sorgt jetzt nicht dafür, dass du gewalttätig bist. Würdest du das generell in Anspruch nehmen? Oder glaubst du, dass es schon Leute gibt, denen du eher weniger empfehlen wirst, solche Spiele zu spielen? So wie du eben gesagt hast, Leute, die prinzipiell vielleicht auch Probleme haben?
Aber es ist jedes freie Entscheidungen. Wenn er das machen will, dann sollte er das auch machen. Ich glaube, dann niemanden schadet. Da wird er ja knalldeuter am Computer ab als an Realität. Ich glaube, das ist auch eine riesige Abspannung, wenn du scheiß Tag hattest. Dann setze dich erstmal vom Computer und ballerst da noch rundherum. Und dann fühlst du dich besser.
Und schalte das ein bisschen das Hirn aus. Wo ist denn für dich, sozusagen, den diese Altersregelung absolut trifft? Du kannst ja nicht in den Laden gehen und dir irgendwie Duh und Drei kaufen. Du, Mann, du droppelst hier meine komplette Moderation in großer. Lass mich mal kurz den Satz zu Ende sagen und du kannst ja noch mal reinhaken, okay? Also offiziell kannst du nicht in den Laden gehen, dir Duh und Drei kaufen, weil es ab 18 ist und du bist 12. Gibt es denn für dich so eine Grenze, ich sag mal eine Geschmacksgrenze, eine Darstellungsgrenze, wo du sagst, das ist für bestimmte Leute, ich sag mal so, wenn du 12 bist und mit 9 oder 8, das ist nicht für deren Finger, Ohren und Augen bestimmt? Okay, aber lass uns jetzt nicht über Grafik und langweilig reden, sondern wirklich über die viel zitierte Gewaltdarstellung und Gewaltausübung. Gibt es für dich da so eine Grenze, wo du sagst, das ist sozusagen nicht für Vorschule oder Erstklässler oder Drittklässler zugänglich zu machen? Sagt der Mann, der mit 12 in der Köln in den Laden gehen kann, eine Gotcha-Pistole kaufen kann und Dumen 3 im Lahnnikofen hat? Abgefahren, ich schieße. Linus, danke für deinen Anruf. Danke für den ersten Anruf in Blue Moon. Einen schönen Abend noch. 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden im Chaosradio Teil 125 über den Jugendschutz. Wie funktioniert Jugendschutz in Deutschland? Wir haben gerade gehört, dass er hervorragend funktioniert. Und wo sollte man da eingreifen? Gibt es für euch Grenzen, wo ihr sagt, sowas muss vielleicht nicht sein? Wir reden darüber, wie Zensur funktioniert, wie Altersfreigaben funktionieren, wie sozusagen auch die Zensierung oder die Einstufung bei Internetseiten funktioniert, an wen man sich wenden kann, wie das mit den Altersfreigaben funktioniert und so. Da hab ich einen Haufen Experten da vom Chaos Computer Club. Die können das alles nachher noch erklären. Ich denke, vor den Nachrichten schaffen wir noch einen, und zwar Alexander aus Potsdam. Hallo Alexander. Krass, krasse Geschichte von Linus, oder?
Ja, aber so hab ich das eigentlich auch schon erlebt. Also, dass der Jugendschutz eigentlich nicht wirklich greift.
Aber dass man in Neukölln mit zwölf in den Laden gehen kann und eine Gottschere aufkaufen kann, ist schon hart.
Das ist schon hart, aber so siehts eben aus.
Und mit Computerspielen ist es wahrscheinlich ja nicht anders.
Nee, das ist wahrscheinlich eher noch leichter.
Wie ist es bei dir? Du bist jetzt 19, damit sieben Jahre älter als Linus, könntest ja mehr oder weniger sein großer Bruder sein. Gibt es für dich so Geschichten, wo du sagst, da ist eine Altersfreigabe absolut richtig und vonnöten?
Eigentlich nicht. Eigentlich sollte jeder eigentlich selbst wissen, was richtig für einen ist.
Und du bist der Meinung, dass sieben- achtjährige Kinder wissen, was für sie richtig ist? Oder sollten da vielleicht Eltern als regulierendes Element?
Nee, da sollten schon die Eltern wissen, was für ihre Kinder richtig ist.
Und wo machst du dann die Grenze? Also ab wann weiß ich selber?
Das ist eine fiese Frankfurter, oder?
Das ist, glaub ich, bei jedem anders.
Wie war's denn bei dir?
Also ich hab eigentlich auch schon mit 14 Ballerspiele gespielt und hab davon keinen Schaden genommen, von daher...
Aber waren es auch schon so, also ich mein, okay, ist jetzt noch nicht so lange her, aber wenn ich jetzt mal zumindest an mich zurückdenke, als ich 14 gespielt hab, da waren, wenn wir sagen Ballerspiele, das waren halt so Pixelhaufen. So ist das natürlich, glaub ich, schon nochmal eine andere Kategorie, als wenn du jetzt wirklich, sag ich mal, die eigenen Geweide spielst.
Beispiel Manhand.
Okay.
Manhand hast du gespielt? Ja. War das einfach für dich, den zu bekommen, das Spiel?
Das lag in der Videothek rum. Da war es noch nicht verboten und dann hab ich es einfach mal gekauft.
Du warst wie alt? Kann man mit 16 in der Videothek überhaupt schon so eine Dinge kaufen? Ich weiß es nicht. Eigentlich sind da Videotheken erst ab 18 zugänglich. Ah nee, vorne die ersten drei Benjamin-Blümchen-Regaler, da kommt man auch so rein.
Da kommst du auch mit unter 12.
Ich bin nicht so oft in Videotheken, deswegen frag ich einfach nur. Also die haben sich auch nicht gewundert, dass du da mit 16 sagst, du willst jetzt hier dieses Spiel kaufen. Höchst interessant. Jugendschutz in Deutschland, so weit ist das also.
Haben die dich überhaupt nach deinem Ausweis gefragt?
Die haben nur gefragt, hast du Geld bei, zahlst du bar?
Aber hast du denn grundsätzlich schon Verständnis, dass es Bemühungen gibt, so Sachen auch zu beschränken? Oder findest du das völlig absurd?
Wenn da irgendwelche durchdrehen, dann sind die Politiker einfach der Meinung, dass man da was ändern muss. Aber wenn man zum Beispiel nach Österreich guckt, wo es praktisch keine Altersfreigabe auf DVDs gibt, da sind ja auch nicht nur Amokläufer.
Stimmt das, Thorsten? Du bist ja da quasi...
Also ist doch nicht, kenne ich mich jetzt überhaupt nicht aus. Aber würde ich mir jetzt vertrauen, also klar.
Ist Deutschland im Europavergleich sozusagen, haben wir die kleinteiligste, schärfste Altersfreigabe?
Ich würde sagen, es ist kaum so gut organisiert wie in Deutschland.
Würde einen auch wundern, wenn hier irgendwelche Sachen nicht reguliert werden.
Wir haben ja schon allein auch diese ganze Bund-Länder-Geschichte, diese Trennung, also wir haben verschiedene Gesetze auch einfach dafür, das sind andere europäische Länder sicherlich einfacher organisiert.
Vor allem sind auch die Freigaben in anderen Ländern viel lockerer.
Was meinst du mit lockerer? Du meinst, dass es halt nicht so viele Abstufungen gibt, weil in Deutschland ist es ja so, dass es eine Freigabe ohne Altersbeschränkung gibt, dann ab sechs Jahre, ab zwölf Jahre, ab sechzehn und dann gar nicht frei für Jugendliche.
Und dann noch eine höhere Freigabe und dann editiert und dann beschlagt.
Es gibt keine höhere Freigabe ab 18 oder keine Jugendfreigabe, oder?
Doch, es gibt noch Bio-JK. Das ist aber auch nur bei Filmen. Da wird halt bestätigt, dass der Film nicht gegen § 131 verstößt, der halt besagt, dass menschenverachtendes Material nicht verbreitet werden darf. Und es gibt halt noch ungeprüft.
Und das wird dann meistens auch beschlagnahmt. Ungeprüft heißt, du hast keine Jugendfreigabe, ganz einfach. Aber es wird nicht automatisch beschlagnahmt, wenn es nicht gegen bestimmte Paragrafen verstößt, also eben zum Beispiel gegen das Strafgesetzbuch.
Ich würde um ganz kurz hier einzugreifen, diese Geschichte, wer stucht was wie wo ein und was bedeutet das in einem Einzelnen und was haben diese einzelnen Altersfreigaben zu tun? Das würde ich gerne nach den Nachrichten weiter erklären, Alexander. Vielleicht an dich noch die Frage. Du hast gesagt, grundsätzlich gibt es bestimmte Dinge, die man erst zwei, drittklässler nicht zugänglich machen sollte. Du hast gesagt, du bist mit 16 in die Videothek gegangen, hast dir das Spiel gekauft, die erst für 18-Jährige zugänglich sind. Ich habe keiner gefragt. Wo ist das Problem, was sollte man ändern?
Also, dass man, wenn man schon strenge Jugendgesetze macht, auch dafür sorgen sollte, dass sie eingehalten werden.
Wie sollte man dafür sorgen?
Ich weiß nicht einfach. Das einzige wäre wahrscheinlich Strafenverhändler, die das dann trotzdem verkaufen.
Interessante These, die werden wir diskutieren. Danke Alexander.
Tschüss.
Spannendes Thema, darüber werden wir noch eine Weile reden. 2, 5 Stunden Chaosradio 125 auf Fritz, 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über den Jugendschutz, ein halbes Jahr nach Emstetten und nach der Forderung der Verbote für Killerspiele, gewaltverherrlichende Musik, Schokomuffins und Otto und Alwin Kaugummis. Mehr nach den Nachrichten.
2007 ist für diese Band ein richtig gutes Jahr. Zwei Echoes und drei Kometen gewonnen. Unter anderem als bester Liveact. Und genau das wollen sie in ihrer Wahlheimat unter Beweis stellen. Kommen im Freitag ab 19.30 Uhr in der Zitadelle Spandau. Silbermond. Einer der besten Live-Hacks Deutschlands. Und das hört man.
3, 5 10. Übrigens mit dem Verbot von Schokoladenmuffins nehme ich zurück.
In der bisherige britische Premierminister Blair ist zum neuen Sondergesandten des Nahostquartetts anernt worden. Das gab die UNO in New York bekannt. In seiner neuen Funktion soll Blair die Friedensbemühungen zwischen Israelis und Palästinensern wieder beleben. Vorrangig ist dabei die Suche nach einer Zweistaatenlösung. Blair hatte das Amt des Regierungschefs am Nachmittag nach zehn Jahren aufgegeben. Anschließend wurde sein Nachfolger Gordon Brown mit der Regierungsbildung beauftragt. Im Radsport gibt es offenbar einen neuen Dopingfall. Matthias Kessler, langjähriger Helfer von Jan Ulrich und Andreas Klöden, wurden im April positiv auf Testosteron getestet. Das gab sein Rennstall Astana bekannt. Kessler wurde zunächst bis zum Ergebnis der B-Probe suspendiert. Er war fest für die am 7. Juli beginnende Tour de France eingeplant. Die Bundesregierung hat ein neues Förderprogramm für Langzeitarbeitslose beschlossen. Arbeitsminister Müntefering stellte im Kabinett seinen sogenannten Kommunal-Kombi-Lohn vor. Der Bund will danach ab Anfang 2008 für einen Zeitraum von drei Jahren die Hälfte des Lohns übernehmen, wenn Kommunen oder Wohlfahrtsverbände Langzeitarbeitslose für bestimmte Tätigkeiten zusätzlich anstellen. Das neue Förderprogramm soll für alle Regionen gelten, in denen die Arbeitslosenquote mehr als 15 Prozent beträgt. Bahnchef Medon bleibt bis zum Jahr 2011 im Amt. Der Aufsichtsrat des Unternehmens teilte nach einer Sitzung mit, dass der Vertrag des 64-Jährigen um drei Jahre verlängert werde. Damit kann Medon die geplante Privatisierung der Bahn weiter vorantreiben. Der Bundestag hat im November grundsätzlich entschieden, das letzte große Staatsunternehmen in Deutschland bis 2009 in Teilen an die Börse zu bringen. In der Nacht wird der Wind weniger und es kühlt ab auf 12 bis 9 Grad. Morgen bleibt es wechselhaft bei 17 bis 19 Grad. Der Verkehr fritzt an 19 Rostock Richtung Wittstock-Dosse zwischen Röbel und Wittstock. Dosse ist ein Schwertransport unterwegs, der nicht überholt werden kann. Dann haben wir A10, Nördlicher Willering, Berliner Ring, Hafenland Richtung Schwandeberg. Zwischen Mühlenbeck und dem Dreieck Pankow besteht Gefahr durch einen defekten Lkw. Dort ist der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Ansonsten sind die Straßen frei. Wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Ist es eigentlich dieser defekte Lkw, der immer auf den Straßen rumsteht, wenn es Stau gibt? Gibt es da nur einen oder gibt es da mehrere?
Ich glaube, der ADAC stellt die ab, damit wir Verkehrsmeldung haben.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1? Dann Fritz in der Prignitz. Jetzt unter 0331 70 97 110.
Wir reden heute im Blue Moon am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Selbstverständlich, das ist der Tag, in dem das Chaosradio auf Fritz stattfindet. Chaosradio Teil 125. Wir reden heute über den Jugendschutz in Deutschland. Wie funktioniert er? Was ist durchzusetzen? Was proklemmt im Moment? Wir haben gerade die krasse Geschichte von Julius gehört. Der sagte, mit 12 überhaupt kein Problem, um sich die Dinger zu kaufen und deshalb 18 freigegeben sind. Also wird das mit dem verbieten verbieten verboten. Ist das wahrscheinlich erst der dritte oder vierte Schritt. Bei mir sind Annett, Torsten und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club, die alle quasi auch Experte auf diesem Gebiet sind und die unter anderem erklären können, wie diese Altersfreigaben zustande kommen, wer das eigentlich macht und sonstige Dinge auch. Wir reden auch irgendwann noch darüber, wie das ist mit Webseiten, die nicht wirklich cool sind, aber erstmal reden wir erst mit Julius und dann mit Antje. Die erste Frau, die in der Sendung über Computerspiele und Jugendschutz anruft. Antje, habt Geduld, Julius gleich, ihr anderen, die ihr gerade am Telefon hängt. Die Leitung ist voll, ich glaube in den nächsten 10 Minuten macht es keinen Sinn anzurufen. Geht nicht weg, wir wollen mit euch diskutieren. Aber nicht, dass ihr jetzt frustriert irgendwie das Telefon in die Ecke schmeißt und sagt, hat keinen Sinn, komm nicht durch. Im Moment sind wir dicke, aber wir würden gerne auch noch mit euch reden. Habt Geduld. 16. Und du zockst oder zockst nicht? Oder wie? Das klingt so ein bisschen, als ob du Schmerzen dabei hast. Ich hab auch manchmal eine Fünf in Mathe. Alles klar. Jugendschutz in Deutschland von einem halben Jahr wurde wieder mal gefordert, dass Killerspiele im Speziellen, das ist natürlich der größte Aufreger, verboten werden sollen.
Können wir kurz über sogenannte Killerspiele reden? Weil der Begriff ist immer ziemlich...
Lass uns den noch von Julius erklären lassen. Wenn er sagt, er zockt, kann er das auch tun. Also was sind bei dir Killerspiele?
Killerspiele sind bei mir auf jeden Fall nicht Counter-Strike. Klar, ja, aber für mich sind mehr Killerspiele sowas wie Postel.
Falls euch das was sagt.
Ne, beschreib mal kurz.
Postel 2, das ist in Deutschland verboten. Und es ist eigentlich ziemlich heftig, da kann man Leute anpinkeln, die in die Körpfe aber, also es ist ziemlich heftig, sowas wie Manhand ungefähr. Und ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich heftig, wir spüren das als für mich ein Killerspiel.
Wir fragen mal die Experten, was ist denn per Definition ein Killerspiel?
Also ich würde mich erstmal gegen den Begriff wehren, du hast halt bei Computerspielen Genre.
Na der taucht überall auf, also muss man den ja definieren.
Ja, es fing halt erst an mit sogenanntem Killerspiel und inzwischen reden wir halt nur von Killerspielen und das ist ja eigentlich mehr eine Bewertung schon. Also ich würde erstmal Ego-Shooter vor allem darunter fassen. Oder solche Spiele, wie Julius eben beschrieben hat, die ich schon gar nicht mehr kenne.
Ja, wobei Counter-Strike, da würden die CS-Zocker sagen, es ist ein Strategiespiel und kein Ego-Shooter. Oder so Sachen wie Far Cry oder so, wo es eher darum geht, Strategien zu entwickeln.
Aber das ist jetzt die Betrachtung aus Sicht des Spiels oder der Spieler. Wie ist denn die Betrachtung von außen, also wie ist denn sozusagen die formale Definition für diese Spiele, bei denen es um die Verbote geht?
Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob es da schon so was wie eine formale Definition gibt. Es ist natürlich, wenn du jetzt von außen so ein Spiel betrachtest und es geht für dich in erster Linie darum, Leute zu töten. Also ich glaube, du musst schon noch einen gewissen Einblick haben bei Counter Strike um zu erkennen, es geht eben nicht nur ums Ballern. Also ich glaube, wenn ich da nur kurz zugucken würde, würde ich vielleicht auch den Eindruck bekommen, da ist keine Strategie dahinter. Ich würde sagen, jemand, der den Begriff Killerspiele verwendet, zeigt schon, dass er eigentlich nur einen oberflächlichen Eindruck hat von diesem Genre oder generell von Computerspielen. So ist meine private Einschätzung.
Guck mal, jeder sagt, dass man in diesen Spielen auf Leute schießt. Leute sind für mich Personen, Menschen, aber eigentlich schießt man ja nur auf Pixel.
Du schießt auf Nullen und Einsen, richtig?
Genau.
Und zwar mit Nullen und Einsen.
Ich finde ganz einfach, genauso wie dieser Bericht im ARD. Welcher? Irgendwie der Höhepunkt, wo die, ähm, also ich hab bloß gehört von dem, ich hab ihn selbst nie gesehen. Weil mir wurde erzählt, dass man halt, also es wurde gesagt, dass, ähm, bei GTA San Andreas, desto mehr Frauen, man vergewaltigt, desto besser ist man. Stimmt überhaupt nicht, das geht wieder in der deutschen, noch der amerikanischen Version. Ich hab beide gespielt. Ähm, genauso, Call of Duty 2 wurde gezeigt. Und, äh, nee, über Call of Duty 2 wurde gesprochen. Man hat gesagt, dass man mit dem Patch halt Hakenkreuzung zu einfügen kann. Gezeigt wurde, aber, ähm, Medal of Honor.
Womit wir auch bei dem Thema dieser Sendung sind. Es wird eine hitzeige Diskussion über Dinge geführt, von denen die wenigsten Menschen, die darüber reden und darüber vor allen Dingen zu entscheiden haben, wissen, worüber sie doch eigentlich reden. Vielleicht können wir auch mit dieser Sendung dazu beitragen. Wir reden ja vorrangig auch über das Thema Jugendschutz. Wie gesagt, von einem halben Jahr wurde wieder mal gefordert, es muss alles verboten werden. Bei der CDU sagt Thürings Innenminister zum Beispiel, grundsätzliches Verbot ist unumgänglich. Der Innenminister von Hessen sagte, junge Leute müssen vor menschenverachtenden Gewaltexzessen geschützt werden. Wie soll denn sowas in der Praxis funktionieren? Was wäre denn deine Vorstellung davon, Julius? Wieso? Man kann auch das Internet verbieten. Können Sie machen, dass es nicht wieder regnet?
Es geht gar nicht. Erst mal ist Deutschland einst die größten Plätze für Computerspiele, weil ich das mal richtig mitgekriegt habe. Was heißt, wenn man in Deutschland diese Spiele verbieten würde, würde die Industrie tierisch darunter leiden. Zweitens, man kann sie nicht verbieten, weil jeder kann sie sich aus dem Internet darunter laden.
Also muss es einen anderen Kontrollmechanismus geben?
Ja.
Wie solltet ihr denn ausschalten?
Außerdem, was verboten ist, macht noch mehr Spaß.
Aber sag mal, wenn jeder aus dem Internet darunter laden kann, dann verdienen ja auch die Firmen kein Geld mehr und würden dann auch keine Spiele mehr produzieren.
Das ist ein schönes Argument.
Ja, das stimmt auch wieder, aber wenn es schon verboten ist und man sie hier nicht kaufen kann, dann kann man sie auch aus dem Internet darunter laden.
Klar, aber dann fehlt den Firmen das Geld, um das nächste Spiel zu produzieren.
Und dir fehlt der Key, um das Spiel zu aktivieren.
Ja, aber wenn man die eh nicht kaufen kann, dann fehlt den Firmen das Geld sowieso schon. Dann kann man sie auch aus dem Internet wieder darunter laden.
Du meinst sozusagen, wenn die Dinger verboten sind und damit kein Umsatz gemacht werden kann, dann kann man sie auch gleich aus dem Netz ziehen.
Genau. Und dann wollte ich mal zum Vorredner noch sagen, wo er gesagt hat, dass es in den anderen Ländern lockerer ist. Ein Film, der ist in Deutschland initiiert, der heißt Der blutige Fahrt Gottes. Kennt ihr den?
Er hört sich so an, als ob ich den nicht mal kennen will, Julius.
Nein, er ist selbst destizverherrlichend. Und ist damit hier auf dem Index gelandet, von einer Brutalität, ist er so wie stopplangsam ungefähr. Ziemlich harmlos eigentlich, aber da er selbst destizverherrlichend ist, ist er hier auf dem Index gelandet.
Pass auf, wie diese Geschichten mit auf dem Index landen funktionieren und was für Leute sind die darüber entscheiden? Darüber werden wir glaube ich in der nächsten Viertelstunde noch mit Thorsten zum Beispiel reden, der kann ein paar Sachen dazu erzählen. Also jetzt aber...
Ich habe aber noch eine kurze Frage an dich. Du hast doch erst gemeint, dass das ja nicht auf Person schießen ist, sondern auf Pixel oder 0 und 1 quasi. Wäre denn das Ganze für dich so reizvoll noch, wenn diese Pixel nicht personalisiert wären, wenn die nicht irgendwie eine menschliche Form hätten? Also hauptsächlich schießen?
Ja, ich mach das eigentlich. Ich brusse mich ab, ja zu gehen. Also ich bin eigentlich hier in der Familie die ruhigste Person von allen. Das einzige, wo ich mal ausfallen werde, ist wörtlich. Aber ansonsten bin ich so eigentlich der Bravsicher. Und ich mach das eigentlich auch bloß zum Abreagieren. Und jetzt zum anderen. Also dieser Film kam zum Beispiel in Russland morgens um neun im Fernsehen. Und hier darf man den nicht mal kaufen. In Italien kam er nachts um zehn.
Woher weißt du das, wenn ich dich fragen darf?
Und höre ich jetzt richtig raus, dass du das nicht so in Ordnung findest, dass der in Deutschland auf dem Index gelandet ist, weil er ja in anderen Ländern... Aber du hast doch gerade selbst erläutert, warum er auf dem Index gelandet ist.
Aber wenn du mal zum Beispiel an deine Freunde denkst, kannst du dir vorstellen, dass du in deinem Freundeskreis jemanden hat, der das vielleicht nicht so ganz differenzieren kann. Also jetzt nicht sagt, okay, das ist halt jetzt ein Film oder das ist ein Computerspiel, der da wo du sagst, ey, also bei dem, der sollte vielleicht besser nicht spielen oder den Film vielleicht besser nicht sehen. Gibt's da so jemand?
Also in meinem Freundeskreis direkt nicht. Ich kenn Leute, bei denen kann ich es nicht genau einschätzen. Aber so in meinem Freundeskreis eigentlich nicht.
Aber das heißt, dass es ja vielleicht dann doch ganz gut sein könnte, dass diesen Film nicht jeder sieht?
Dieser Film hat eigentlich, ja, es ist vielleicht ganz gut, dass ihn nicht jeder sieht, aber dieser Film hat bereits Kultstatus. Man braucht eigentlich Busfragen und jeder kennt ihn, jeder hat von ihm schon mal gehört.
Lass uns raten, weil er indiziert ist.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Na ja, klar, wenn irgendwie alle drüber reden und es ist verboten und man macht nicht irgendwie, ey, ich hab letztens irgendwie Bimmel und Bommel fahren über die Alpen in den Urlaub gesehen, sondern du sagst, ey, gibt es hier einen krassen Film und so. Das ist natürlich ein viel größeres Thema, über das man reden kann. Viel interessanter, klar. Okay, pass auf, letzte Frage an dich, weil jetzt brummen hier die Leitungen. Du hast gerade auch gesagt, es gibt bestimmte Dinge, also ein paar Leute, wo du sagst, da bist du dir nicht sicher, ob das für die zugänglich sein sollte. Was machen wir jetzt hier mit diesem Jugendschutz in Deutschland? Verbieten ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht so eine Option. Also wie sollte man das regeln, dass da jetzt nicht irgendwie, ich sag mal, Kinder im weitesten Sinne, obwohl es auch verschiedene Reife gerade in der Formulierung gibt, dass nicht jeder sozusagen an GT-Rs, an Andreas oder an den Filmen oder was auch immer rankommt. Was kann man da machen?
Na, auf jeden Fall denke ich mal, ein Problem sind die Eltern. So, ich hab mal einen Brief gelesen von einem Verkäufer aus irgendeinem Videolan, der sich tierisch darüber aufgeregt hat, dass diese Eltern eigentlich nichts machen. Die gehen mit ihren Kindern in den Laden, Kind sucht das Spiel aus, drückt es der Mutter in die Hand und die kauft es.
Ohne drauf zu gucken?
Genau, ohne drauf zu gucken. Der Verkäufer weist die Eltern sogar noch darauf hin, dass dieses Spiel ab 16 oder ab 18 ist.
Soll er doch.
Und dann sagt er halt noch, hat er ihnen auch mal gesagt, dass sie sich doch mal miteinander angucken sollen. Und damit die Eltern entscheiden, ob dieses Spiel für ihren Sohn gut genug ist. Und dann sagen die Eltern, oh nee, da muss ich mich damit jetzt ja auch noch beschäftigen.
Oder aber ich hab auch selber lange in einem Plattenladen gearbeitet, wo natürlich auch Videos und DVDs hinzuverkauft wurden, wo dann also Eltern zu dir auch quasi, der Verkäufer, der die Verantwortung dafür trägt, sagen, glauben sie etwa, mein Kind ist nicht reif dafür? Mit so einem Ton, wo du dann echt machtlos dastehst und den Leuten einfach nur die Anuren ziehen wirst. Julius, danke für den Anruf. Ich wünsche dir eine hervorragende Nacht.
Ja, euch auch.
Verknote dir nicht die Augen beim Zocken. 0331 70 97 110, ich freue mich. Hallo, Anche. Wir machen so viele Sendungen zum Thema und du bist das erste Mädchen, das anruft. Ich freue mich. Warte mal, ganz kurz. An was für einem Telefon bist du da gerade? Klingt fürchterlich. Hast du einen Festnisanschluss? Können wir dich zurückrufen? Hast du nicht? Kannst du mal zum Fenster gehen?
Warte.
Du klingst, als ob du im Inneren einer Biene wärst. Auch nicht wirklich. Das ist übrigens Live-Radio. Hört den Blumen auf Fritz. Und was da brummt, ist Antje, die versucht, eine bessere Verbindung zu kriegen.
Hat Michja schon gesagt, wie alt sie ist? 21, okay.
Pass mal, vielleicht kriegen wir das hin. Okay, alles klar. Jugendschutz, jetzt bleib mal ruhig, Große. Alles klar. Ach, fantastisch. Nicht bewegen. Großartig. Okay. Wir reden über das Thema Jugendschutz. Wir haben jetzt schon ein paar Leute gehört, die sagen, es ist überhaupt kein Problem, auch an Dinge ranzukommen, auch wenn die noch nicht offiziell für einzugänglich sein sollten. Wie siehst du das? Wie sind deine Erfahrungen?
Ich hab mit 15 so Counter-Strike gespielt, auch unglaublich gerne. Aber ich meine, es hängt nicht von Jugendschutz und von den Gesetzen ab. Ich meine, wir sind eigentlich schon ganz okay, dass es eingeteilt ist ab 6, ab 12, ab 18. Und wer rankommen will, der kommt sowieso ran, auch wenn er noch jünger ist. Ich denke, es ist ein Problem der Gesellschaft.
Naja, aber es ist ein Problem der Gesellschaft. Es ist immer so ein bisschen so eine einfache Entschuldigung, die man von sich werfen kann und sagen, dann müsste sich die Gesellschaft darum kümmern, dann kommen nämlich die Politiker und sagen denen verbieten was.
Nein, nein, ich sag mal, es ist ein Problem von uns allen so. Wir sind einfach viel zu sehr konzentriert auf arbeiten gehen und viel Geld verdienen und haben überhaupt nicht mehr wirklich Zeit für die Familie, sondern machen uns immer noch was zusammen. Und wie Julius gerade, ne, war er doch, eben schon gesagt hat, so die Eltern interessieren sich einfach nicht mehr dafür, was ihre Kinder machen. Also ich hab von zu Hause gelernt, einfach wenn jemand schlägt, das tut ihm weh, das macht man nicht. Und als ich klein war und ich gesagt hab, oh du blöde Kuh, so, dann hab ich mich schon geschämt alleine, weil ich blöde Kuh gesetzt hab. Und wenn ich die Kinder jetzt so sehe, die kriegen irgendwie nicht mehr mit, was ist richtig, was ist falsch, die Werte, die haben sich irgendwie total verschoben für mich. Und dann fängt es einfach an. Und irgendwann wird halt nicht mehr unterschieden, wenn die ihn jetzt verkühlen, das ist halt schlecht, weißt du? Und ich denke einfach nicht, dass die Gewalt, die im Moment hier herrscht, dass es an Videospielen und an Fernsehen liegt. Ich denke einfach, es ist ein Problem, was unsere Gesellschaft hat, dass niemand mehr auf den anderen achtet und dass wir uns irgendwo voneinander entfernen und uns immer fremder werden, finde ich. Ich denke daran nicht.
Das würde ich so unterschreiben.
Bist du denn an der Meinung, wenn Jugendmedienschutz an sich so schwer greift, dass er total überflüssig ist?
Ja, ich finde, man sollte den, so wie er jetzt besteht, ist er okay, so dass man weiß, man kann rausgucken, mein Kind ist 7, der ist ab 6 freigehen, und ab 12 muss ich ihn vielleicht mir vorher mal angucken und dann selber entscheiden, ob ich das meinem Kind zeige. Aber ich finde, so wie er jetzt ist, ist er eigentlich okay. Man hat eine nette Stufen drin, die werden vorher durchgeguckt. Ich finde es eigentlich okay.
Cool, wenn wir mehr Leute hätten, die ungefähr so denken würden, dann würde der bestehende Jugendmedienschutz wahrscheinlich doch ein bisschen mehr greifen.
Antje, wie war das bei dir, als du angefangen hast, CS zu zocken? Haben deine Eltern mit dir drauf geguckt? Habt ihr darüber diskutiert oder war das egal?
Also ich hab da nicht unbedingt, ich hab mich gestritten viel mit meiner Mutter und war selten zu Hause. Also ich war nicht so, also seltener zu Hause, als dass ich anderswo war. Wenn ich zu Hause geschlafen hab, dann war das auch schon viel.
Das heißt, seine Mutter war schon froh, wenn sie dich gesehen hat und dann wurde nicht noch darüber diskutiert, auf welchem Level du jetzt bist?
Ja, nicht unbedingt. Es war dann so, naja, komm doch bitte nach Hause und mach erst Hausaufgaben und dann gehste weg. Ich bin dann aber nach der Schule, also ich bin noch zu viel im Lernjahr. Und bin dann aber nicht nach Hause gefahren, sondern hab ich mich mit Kumpels getroffen und hab dann da irgendwo ein Hobby entwickelt. Also sie wusste das nicht, aber es war ein Spiel. Und irgendwann, ich war auch leicht gelangseilt nach einer Weile, weil es ist immer dasselbe. Und man versucht die Bösen auszuschalten, also in Anführungsstrichen.
Aber du hattest so mit so Splatter-Filmen, äh, Spielen, hattest du damit ein Problem?
Nicht unbedingt. Ich hab mich da dann auch relativ schnell von entfernt. Aber ich muss mal sagen, hier zu Julius meinte, der blutige Pfad Gottes, ne? Das ist einer meiner Lieblingsfilme, muss ich jetzt mal sagen, wo gestehen. Und ich hab den als Kauf-DVD in Deutschland gekauft. Normal, in der Bibliothek. Der ist jetzt, ich wusste gar nicht, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass der auf dem Inlex ist.
Das kriegen wir auf jeden Fall aus, wie gerade der aktuelle Stand der Dinge ist.
Und so filmen, er ist jetzt nicht schlimmer als Terminator oder irgendwas anderes. Ich meine, es geht halt um zwei Brüder, die da hoffenweise Leute verkrotzen, die Verbrechen begehen, weil sie der Männnis sind. Jeder, der ein Verbrechen begeht, ist halt, egal ob es ein kleiner Dealer ist oder ein großer, ne? Ist ein Verbrecher und der gehört nicht auf diese Welt und verhandelt die nur und dann starten sie da eben von Gott befohlenen Rache-Feldzug, sozusagen.
Also ob dieser Feldzug von Gott wirklich befohlen ist, darüber kann man auch diskutieren, über den Film reden wir gleich. Torsten vom CTC würde was sagen.
Eine kurze Frage, kannst du uns sagen, wann der Film produziert wurde? Hast du da eine Ahnung, aus welchem Jahr der ungefähr ist? Also eher was Neues, oder eher so aus den 80er Jahren, oder...
1998, 1999, 2000 vielleicht, so in dem Dreh.
Hat da irgendjemand mitgespielt, den man kennt?
Oder ist es...
Jakob, hattest du es?
Ich muss mal hier mein Mikrofon holen. Also das Internet-Lexikon sagt von 99 ist von einem Typen namens Troy Duffy, Pippa Poe. Okay, also das kriegen wir auf jeden Fall noch raus, auch warum der Film auf dem Index steht. Das ist aber eine andere Geschichte. Antje, ich danke dir sehr für deinen Anruf und für deine Einschätzung zum Thema Jugendschutz, wie es funktioniert und wie soll es in der Praxis umgesetzt werden. Ihr seid im Blumen auf Fritz, 0331, 70 97 110. Wir reden gleich mit euch weiter, aber vorher vielleicht können Thorsten und Annett was sagen zu diesen ganzen Altersfreigaben. Was heißen die und wer gibt die überhaupt raus?
Also, da müsst ihr uns bremsen, wenn es zu langweilig wird. Und zwar ist es ein ziemlich schwieriges Geflecht. Das hängt schon mal davon ab, welches Medium es ist. Also, ob Kinofilm, DVD, ob du es im Fernsehen ausstrahlen willst, ob es ein Computerspiel ist. Je nachdem ist eine unterschiedliche Einrichtung dafür zuständig. Du hast in Deutschland dieses System der Freiwilligen Selbstkontrolle. Das heißt eigentlich keine staatlichen Einrichtungen, sondern die Produzenten verpflichten sich, ihr Produkt vorher einem Gremium zu zeigen. Die beurteilen das, bewerten es und stufen es entsprechend ein. Die Alterseinstufungen, die er jetzt schon genannt hat, die sind gesetzlich vorgegeben. Das heißt, die FSK kann jetzt nicht zum Beispiel sagen, der Film ist so oder zwischen, der ist jetzt ab 8 oder ab 10. Nein, die sind gesetzlich vorgegeben. Die stehen im Jugendschutzgesetz. Und das ist halt dann diese Einstufung ohne Altersfreigabe ab 6, ab 12. Ab 12 dann noch Parental Guidance. Also halt mit den Eltern kannst du das gucken, wenn du jünger bist. Ab 16, ab 18. Und die sind verpflichtend. Du darfst zum Beispiel im Kino als Kinobesitzer Filme nicht Leuten zeigen, die jünger sind. Ansonsten machst du dich Strafe, musst Strafen zahlen.
Das heißt, du bist auch verpflichtet sozusagen, am Eingang zu kontrollieren, wer betritt diesen Film.
Genau, genau. Und du hast also schon, das ist sozusagen die älteste Regelung mit der FSK. Die wurde Ende der 40er schon gegründet. Das ist das älteste und funktionierendste System.
Das ist die freiwillige Selbstkontrolle.
Und da hast du eigentlich schon dieses System. Da ist ein Gremium, das bewertet die Filme. Kontrolliert wird es aber dann von Leuten, die eigentlich an dir verdienen wollen. Also eigentlich schon mal suspekt, dass du sagst, okay, der Kinobetreiber muss dir jetzt sagen, du siehst ihn nicht, er kann nicht an dir verdienen. Aber mein Eindruck ist, dass dieses System noch relativ gut funktioniert. Wir haben jetzt die Beispiele gehört von den Anrufern, dass im Handel mit Computerspielen sieht es schon ein bisschen anders aus. Da müsste eigentlich auch der Handler darauf achten, dass die USK-Frage haben, die ähnlich verpflichtend sind, ähnlich bin, dass ich eben den Kids dann so ein Spiel nicht verkaufe. Und mich eben an meine eigenen Gewinne bringe. Aber so ist halt das System. Und müsste eigentlich angehalten werden. Und es gibt eigentlich auch relativ hohe Strafen, wenn du halt zuwiderhandelst. Und die USK, das ist die unabhängige Selbstkontrolle für Computerspiele. Und die sagen eben, ihr System funktioniert, weil bisher gibt es noch keinen Händler, der irgendwie angeklagt wurde. So und die USK kann eben nur eins tun. Sie kann Spiele ansehen, sie kann sie bewerten, sie kann sie mit dem entsprechenden Siegel auch versehen. Kontrollieren muss es dann wieder der Handel.
Gucken die jedes Spiel durch?
Sie gucken an sich jedes Spiel, was ihnen vorgelegt wird. Spiele, die nicht vorgelegt werden, kriegen sofort keine Jugendfreigabe, weil sie eben von keinem Gremium hier in Deutschland begutachtet wurden. Es gibt so ein System, wenn du erkennst, es ist jetzt ein Sudoku oder es ist irgendwie nur ein Lernspiel oder es ist irgendwie Tetris 5.0 oder was. Da gibt es ein relativ kleines Gremium, kurzes Verfahren. Okay, wir wissen ohne Altersfreigabe. Ansonsten wird jedes Spiel von denen durchgesehen. Das ist nochmal ein spezielles Verfahren. Sie haben spezielle Computertester, die die Spiele durchspielen. Das heißt, die haben auch von den Produzenten alle Cheats, alle Lösungswege, alles Mögliche. Und die stellen so eine Art Präsentation zusammen. Für dann das Prüfgremium. Aber man kann sich jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass ein Prüfgremium von 5, 6 Leuten das stundenlang ein Spiel durchspielt. Die meisten Spiele sind ja auch nicht mehr richtig durchzuspielen. Die Tester präsentieren die Spiele, das Gremium prüft dann diese Präsentation, stuft die Spiele ein und dann kriegen sie das entsprechende Siegel.
Wie ist das im Kino bei diesen Freigaben 6, 12, 14, 16, 18? Gibt es da so eine Grenze, dass man sagt, bis sechs Jahren darf keiner eine Ohrfeige bekommen, bis zwölf darf man keine nackten Menschen sehen?
Nein, so ist es halt gar nicht. Du hast halt keinen Katalog. Das hieß ja eben schon daran, dass es immer ein Gremium ist, dass diese Filme sieht, immer fünf bis sechs Leute, je nach Einrichtung. Und du hast immer auch die Möglichkeit der Berufung. Das heißt, du kannst auch den Fall haben, FSK sagt ab sechs, Produzent sagt, ich würde aber sagen, der hat eine Altersfrage, Berufung, neues Gremium und die kommen dann zu dem Beschluss ab zwölf. Das heißt, du kannst immer verschiedene Meinungen haben. Es gibt eben keinen Katalog, es gibt ein Gremium. Die treffen die Entscheidung und die machen sich immer ein Bild. Deswegen kannst du nicht so klar sagen, nackte Menschen ja, nein, Ohrfeige ja, nein, Beschimpfungen ja, nein. Das ist halt immer der konkrete Film, das konkrete Produkt.
Das ist Chaosradio 125, wir reden über den Lidenschutz in Deutschland. Ich musste gerade hören, dass hier Beschwerden kommen. Ihr seid übrigens in Blumen auf Fritz, warte mal ganz kurz, ist die Uhrzeit. In elektrisch. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt Chaos Radio, heute ist halb 125. Wir reden mit Frank, Annett und Thorsten vom Chaos Computer Club über Jugendschutz. Wie funktioniert das in Deutschland gerade? Wir haben jetzt eine Stunde lang schon mit euch telefoniert. Ganz kurz vielleicht die Geschichte. Frank hat gerade erzählt im Chat, die Adresse möchtest du bitte nochmal sagen?
Ne, ne, das war hier sozusagen quasi ein Insider.
Ah, verstehe. Gab es Beschwerden über die Musik? Ich fand die Musik super, davon kommt noch mehr. Das waren die Mad Caddies. Stay of Mind, wer sowas im Sommer nicht hört, ist auch kein Erdbeereis. So, weiter im Text, wir haben euch gefragt, was haltet ihr von der aktuellen Verbotsregelung im Jugendschutz? Funktioniert die, die immer wieder geforderte, allgemeine, das allgemeine Verbot von Jugend und, wie heißt es so schön, Menschen verherrlichen Gewaltexzessen, die von der Politik immer wieder gefordert wird?
Nein, Menschen verachten.
Menschen verachten, Menschen verherrlichen, blödsinn. Menschen verachten, genau. Siehst, da komme ich schon durcheinander mit dem Kram. Inwieweit greift das, wie sind eure Erfahrungen mit solchen Geschichten? Kann man mit zwölf Sachen kaufen, die schon ab 18 sind? Und was haltet ihr davon, dass es bestimmte Einstufungen gibt? Wir haben auch schon ein paar Geschichten gehört, wie diese Alterseinstufungen bei der FSK und bei der USK funktionieren. Und telefonieren jetzt mit Daniel. Hallo Daniel, guten Abend. 13 Jahre alt, aus Kleinmachno.
Genau. Und ich habe zwei Sachen zu sagen. Und zwar erstens wollte ich was fragen, auch zur Jugendschutz natürlich. Und dann wollte ich noch was erzählen, was so ein bisschen damit natürlich zusammenhängt. Und also erst mal zu meiner Frage. Wenn ich jetzt mir was kaufe, also ein Spiel ab 16, ich bin ja 13 und ich gehe jetzt in die Videothek und kaufen wir dann ein Spiel ab 16 und ja der Verkauf, das mir auch von der Geld machen möchte, der macht sich auf jeden Fall strafbar, der Verkäufer. Aber mache ich mich damit auch strafbar, wenn ich so was kaufe?
Da du noch nicht, ich bin kein Strafrechtler, aber da du noch nicht 14 bist und damit noch nicht strafmündig bist, könnten deine Eltern zumindest sagen, könnten zum Verkäufer gehen und können sagen, sie geben das Spiel zurück und sie hätten gerne den vollen Kaufpreis zurück und könnten ihn auch noch anzeigen.
Aber meine Eltern machen sich nicht strafbar oder so, wenn ich so ein Spiel kaufe.
Also soweit ich weiß machst du dich nicht strafbar selber und wenn zum Beispiel deine Eltern es kaufen und dir dann geben, machen sie sich auch nicht strafbar.
Aber es darf dir nicht verkauft werden.
Ja, also und dann jetzt eben zu der zweiten Sache generell. Und zwar erstmal die Regelung und so, die finde ich auch alle ganz gut. Und das ist ja in Deutschland alles ganz gut festgelegt, wie es sein sollte. Aber wie gesagt, das ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht so. Und du hast auch schon gesagt oder Lino am Anfang hat schon gesagt, mit im Laden gehen oder so oder irgendwo in Neukölln Spiel kaufen oder so, es ist dem Verkäufer egal. Ich brauche dafür eigentlich nicht mal nach Neukölln zu gehen oder so. Und zwar mit 13 darf ich ja schon ein Girokonto haben und das habe ich auch. Und ich bin damit bei Amazon angemeldet und die fragen gar nicht nach dem Alter. Also ich kann mir das Spiel auf 16 bestellen. Ich habe den nämlich noch gar nicht besprochen. Da dachte ich irgendwie weiß es noch keiner. Und da fragte man sich der Postbote und die fragen nicht nach dem Alter. Wenn ich jetzt sage, habe ich schon gemacht oder habe ich nicht, ist ja egal.
Bei Amazon wollen die keinen Altersnachweis?
Nee, ich habe mich da mal angemeldet, nicht um so ein Spiel zu kaufen. Ich bin ja jetzt nicht so ein Freak oder so. Nicht, dass ihr was Falsches denkt von mir. Aber um mir was anderes Kleines zu kaufen, haben die mir geliefert. Und dann irgendwann dachte ich mir, ja, mal gucken, ob die nach dem Alter fragen und haben sie nicht gemacht. Und ja, es kommt dann zwei Tage später, als ob du dir da ein Schachset bestellt.
Das ist interessant, weil es gibt natürlich eine Menge Merchandise oder Versandhäuser, wo man Filme, DVDs, Videos kaufen kann, die eindeutig darauf hinweisen, wenn es Geschichten gibt, die mit einer Altersfreigabe versehen sind, dass man da eine Ausweiskopie mitschicken muss. Wenn das bei Amazon nicht geht.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das Beispiel ab 18 auch ist, aber ab 16 kann ich auf jeden Fall.
Also ich kenne es von 18er-DVDs, da muss man, wenn man die haben will, ein Altersnachweis mitschicken.
Ja, also keine Ahnung.
Das wäre doch mal ein Thema, wo man mal bei Amazon nachfragen könnte. Prima Idee, ich schreibe ihn mal auf, da frage ich demnächst gleich mal nach. So viel zum Thema, es muss alles verboten werden, weil Jugendliche werden versaut.
Es gibt ja schon auch die Bestrebungen, oder es gab zumindest jetzt den Wunsch oder die Idee von einigen Politikern, dann diese ganzen kritischen Spiele einfach ganz zu verbieten. Das heißt also nicht diese Altersfreigaben, sondern einfach sagen, gibt es nicht weg, darf nicht verkauft werden, am besten gar nicht hergestellt werden und geht alle zum Teufel, wir wollen eure Spiele nicht. Wäre denn das ein denkbarer Weg, um diese Spiele weg zu bekommen oder die eben gar nicht mehr zugänglich zu machen?
Da brauche ich jetzt nicht die anderen Hörer wiederholen. Ich habe genau dieselbe Meinung. Man kann es gar nicht verbieten. Es ist auch Unsinn, hatte ich ja vorhin auch gesagt, mit der Palette, die zutrifft. Ab wann jetzt so ein Spieler aggressiv wird dadurch und irgendwelche Gewalttaten begehen kann. Ich finde, dass diese Palette, was noch dazugehört, die ganzen sozialen Geschichten und so, das ist alles so breit. Und da nehmen die Spiele so einen kleinen Teil nur ein. Und wenn man die einfach verbieten würde, ja, was bringt es dann? Also, er würde sich trotzdem besorgen, wenn er dann die sozialen Probleme und so hat. Und ja, bringt überhaupt nichts.
Es gibt ja auch die Frage oder die These, dass sich besonders Kinder und Jugendliche, die sowieso schon ein sehr hohes Aggressionspotenzial haben, sich genau diese Spiele aussuchen. Würdest du dem eher zustimmen oder würdest du sagen, dass es da für dich erstmal keinen Zusammenhang gibt?
Doch, würde ich schon sagen, weil, keine Ahnung, es wird immer gesagt, es ist so ein Ventil für Wut oder für Druck. Also, das kann ich nicht verstehen. Doch, es ist schon so, dass die kleineren oder so, wenn die dann viele Aggressionen haben oder so, und dass sie sich dann öfters kaufen oder dass sie sofort zu dem Regal gehen, wo die Spiele stehen oder so, weil das bei denen vielleicht einfach so ein Zusammenhang ist mit den anderen Sachen, die sie noch erleben und so, dass es bei denen dazugehört. Aber es ist bei ganz vielen jedem anders, finde ich.
Wer sind jetzt genau die kleineren?
Die kleineren sind die, die die Spiele nicht spielen dürfen. Also, die im Counter-Swipe spielen und unter 16 sind und so was eben. Also, die Jünger sind als Erlaub für das Spiel.
Und meinst du, dass man sie vielleicht auch vor diesen Spielen schützen sollte? Also, im Moment muss man nicht immer nur vom Verbot reden, sondern dass man auch sagt, ist es mir einfach auch besser, wenn sie sie nicht spielen oder wie siehst du das?
Ja, natürlich müssen sie geschützt werden. Aber ja, im Prinzip können ja nur die Eltern schützen, weil die Jugendamt können ja nicht überall klingeln und gucken, was spielen sie für Spiele und ja, letzten Endes kommen die Kinder auch selber an die Spiele ran und ja, aber es gibt ihnen ganz viele Eltern, die ja nicht die Verantwortung übernehmen und so. Und das ist natürlich ganz schwierig, aber das kann man eben nicht anders lösen, als dass die Eltern da aufpassen.
Hast du eine Idee oder eine Vorstellung, warum Eltern das nicht wahrnehmen? Ich meine, ist das Ignoranz oder warum kümmern sie sich nicht darum?
Ja, also Eltern sind ja Schutzbefohlen, aber ja, wenn die es nicht wahrnehmen, dann haben die andere Probleme oder kümmern sich nicht um ihr Kind. Also beschäftigen sie sich mehr mit sich selbst und das Kind ist ihnen egal. Die haben das Kind einfach bekommen und sind nicht zur Verantwortung gewusst. Also ja, das ist bescheuert, weil da könnte das Kind auch nichts für. Aber letztendlich liegt es eben an den Eltern und die haben vielleicht ihre eigenen Sachen und meinen, dass das nicht so wichtig ist oder das läuft schon mit dem Kind oder dass sie dann sich selber was einreden, keine Ahnung.
Also auch vielleicht gar nicht wissen, was ihr Kind da spielt, meinst du?
Genau, ja, das ist auch einfach, vor seinen Eltern zu verstecken, was man spielt oder so. Also wenn man jetzt nicht die Eltern hat, die da ganz streng sind und nachgucken, was man hat, das ist nicht so schwierig. Aber die Eltern müssen einfach schon den Willen haben und vielleicht wissen auch gar nicht so viele Eltern, dass es die Gefahr gibt und denken von ihrem Kind, ja, das würde sowas eh nie machen und würde er nicht spielen und so. Weil die Eltern vielleicht einfach eine andere Einstellung haben. Also wenn die Eltern denken, ja, so eine Spiele sind ja eklig und spiele ich nicht, dann denken die automatisch, dass ihr Kinder auch nicht so was spielen würden.
Würde es vielleicht helfen, wenn diese Altersempfehlungen, also jetzt sind es ja Freigaben, und wenn es denn, also wir hatten ja in Deutschland das System, dass das eigentlich Empfehlungen waren, wenn die, sag ich mal, ein bisschen differenzierter wären als einfach nur 12, 14, 16, 18 oder so was, wenn da genauer erklärt werden würde, warum es jetzt eine bestimmte Einstufung geben würde. Also da gibt es ja das, wie heißt das, PEGI-System.
Torsten hat ja so eine wunderbare Liste gehabt, vielleicht kannst du davon nochmal was berichten.
Erzähl doch mal, wie dieses PEGI-System funktioniert. Das scheint mir, von dem weiß ich jetzt, wie viel es gelangt.
Ich wollte ganz kurz, bevor wir zum PEGI kommen, ganz kurz noch was anmerken, Daniel. Du hast gerade gesagt, dass man bei Amazon quasi mit 13 Sachen bestellen kann, die ab 18 sind, da guckt keiner.
Ab 18 nicht, ab 16 hab ich gesagt.
Okay, ich habe gerade mal versucht, was zu bestellen, was eine Altersfreigabe ist. Da sagt mir, dass Ihre Bestellung erhält einen Artikel mit einer Altersfreigabe. Die Lieferung muss vom Empfänger persönlich entgegengenommen werden. Bitte bestätigen Sie Alter und Identität. Und dann muss im Endeffekt der Postbote dann eben gucken, ob du dafür...
Was hast du dir da angeguckt, ab 18 oder ab 16?
Ich hatte gerade einen 18er.
Ich hab das mit 16 gemacht.
Dann machen wir Folgendes, dann wird jetzt Torsten kurz was erzählen zu der PEGI einstufen und ich versuche noch mal einen 16er zu kriegen.
Okay, also ein schnell eingeschrumbes Kurzreferat. Also PEGI ist sozusagen europäische Alternative zu der USK. Also USK ist eine deutsche Einrichtung, bewertet deutsche, also Spiele, die in Deutschland erscheinen, mit verpflichtenden Altersfreigaben. Und PEGI ist halt so ein System, wo man sich selbst klassifizieren kann als Produzent. Man hat da verschiedene Fragen, kann sich da einsortieren. Und dann kommt halt die entsprechende PEGI-Freigabe raus. Und die kann zum Teil halt differieren mit den USK-Freigaben. Das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Das ist mehr eine Empfehlung und keine verpflichtende Freigabe. Und PEGI hat noch verschiedene Symbole, die ich eigentlich ganz gut finde. Und die zeigen zum Beispiel, ob das Spiel vulgäre Sprache enthält. Verzeihung. Ob es Diskriminierung zeigt, ob es Drogenkonsum verharmlost, ob es Kinderängstigen könnte, ob es Glücksspielelemente hat, was sicherlich auf die wenigsten Spiele zutrifft, ob es Nackt- oder Sexdarstellungen enthält und ob es Gewaltdarstellungen enthält. Also die Symbole kann ich jetzt im Radio nicht nachstellen, aber die sind halt entsprechend immer zu der Bedeutung. Das heißt, ich kriege als potenzieller Käufer noch mal so eine mehr oder weniger objektive Information hinzu. Denn an sich, das wirst du ja wissen, wenn du Spiele kaufst, die Packung ist ja voller Bilder und Grafiken, aber ich kriege halt als Elternteil keine Infos, was da mein Kind wirklich zu sehen bekommt. Und diese Pegisymbole können also ein leichter Hinweis sein, was dieses Spiel enthält. Ist aber eben nicht unbedingt das deutsche System.
Ja, und dann gibt es ja wieder die Sachen, dass entweder das jemand, also jetzt muss ich ein bisschen weiter ausholen, um meine Gedanken zu begründen, also entweder kauft es dann jemand, der das kaufen darf, also das Elternteil, oder das Kind kommt da irgendwie ran. Also wenn das Kind das kauft, dann ist ja egal, was drauf steht auf der Packung, weil wenn das Kind dran kommt und schmeißt die Packung weg und spielt das Spiel. Aber ich glaube ja auch auf den Zigaretten, wo der auch vergrößert, was da drauf steht und so. Und Zigaretten werden ja dann auch von den Leuten gekauft, die sie kaufen dürfen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das bei denen da was verändert hat, im Prinzip, also im Zusammenhang, ob das Zigaretten gefährlicher sind oder so, weil es da jetzt größer drauf steht. Aber ich finde schon das System gut, dass wenn jetzt jemand das kauft, also ein Vater, und sagt für seinen Sohn, okay, ist jetzt was anderes als bei den Zigaretten, war ein bisschen dummes Beispiel. Aber auf jeden Fall, wenn da ein Symbol drauf ist, Vulgärsprache, dass er das dann genau sieht, dass sein Kind dann sowas spielen wird, das finde ich schon ganz gut. Aber ich weiß nicht so richtig, ob das Kinder das spielen, also die es nicht spielen dürfen, ob das daran liegt, dass die Eltern einfach nicht verstehen, dass das steht ab 16 oder so. Aber ich glaube schon, dass das dann schon sowas reduzieren würde.
Also kann ich jetzt dem entnehmen, dass wenn da auf dem Spiel nach deutscher Altersfreigabe steht ab 16, dass du dann auch der Meinung bist, dass Kinder oder Jugendliche unter 16, für die vielleicht das Spiel noch nicht so geeignet ist, oder der Film?
Ja, ist immer unterschiedlich. Haben ja auch alle vor mir schon gesagt. Aber man könnte ja jetzt nicht den Unterschied machen, weil wenn jetzt einer sagt, ich bin dafür reif genug und ich darf so spielen und jemand anders verträgt sowas nicht, dann fragt der sicher, wieso darf der das spielen und ich nicht. Das ist ja bescheuert. Das kann man ja noch weniger durchsetzen als so ein gesamtes Verbot. Ja, schwierig eben. Aber deshalb finde ich die ganzen Regelungen, wie das festgelegt ist, wie das sein soll. Die Spieler sind 16, die haben 12 und die haben 18. Das finde ich richtig gut. Aber irgendwie, dass dann auch so große Versandhänder wie Amazon sich so etwas erlauben, das finde ich dann ein bisschen komisch.
Du hast übrigens Recht. Ich habe jetzt gerade versucht, Quake 4 zu bestellen. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Das steht dran bitte ab 16. Also ich habe die 16 überschritten, aber es würde mir quasi ohne Altersnachweis ausgeliefert werden. Lieber Daniel, alle anderen, die anrufen. Da wird sich Fritz in den nächsten Tagen darum kümmern. Wir rufen bei Amazon mal an und fragen, was das soll. Super. Danke für den Anruf. Freuen wir nach, die Leitungen brummen ohne Ende. Jetzt haben schon ein paar Leute Mails geschrieben oder ins Board geschrieben. Wir kommen nicht durch. Wir würden gerne mitdiskutieren. Ihr könnt sowohl online mitdiskutieren auf fritz.de im Fritz-Board oder auch bei chaosradio.ccc.de. Ich hoffe, die war richtig. Auch damit machen im Chat. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. Ich sage mal grob vorsichtig, noch halbe Stunde. Dann dürfte es wahrscheinlich wieder Luft geben, bis ihr hier mitdiskutieren könnt zum Thema. Der nächste am Telefon wartet schon ziemlich lange. Das ist auf jeden Fall Frederik aus Zeuten, 14 Jahre alt. Hallo Frederik. Danke für die Geduld.
Ja, ich wollte mal erstens was sagen zu Counter-Strike. Da gibt es ja im Internet so Videos auf MyVideo oder sowas, die man sich da angucken kann, wo bestimmte Personen da spielen. Und irgendwie, ich finde das ziemlich langweilig. Und das verstehe ich nicht, wie Leute da stundenlang dran sitzen können.
Bist du sonst ein Computerspieler?
Ja, ich spiele schon, aber jetzt nicht so ein Freak.
Was spielst du?
Na ja, also alles quer durch die Reihe.
Na komm, sag mal was.
Ähm, ja, Golfspiele halt und bisschen Ego-Shooter halt auch.
Ego-Shooter, aber nicht Counter-Strike?
Nein, Counter-Strike nicht.
Welche Shooter sind es denn dann?
So eher zweiter Weltkrieg-Shooter und so.
Wo ist da der Unterschied zu Counter-Strike? Also abgesehen vom Plot?
Ja, Counter-Strike ist halt wie schon gesagt taktisch erst mal. Aber auch dieses Spiel, was ich jetzt meine von Zweiter Weltkrieg, ist halt auch taktisch.
Was, Medal of Honor oder was?
Nee, nee, Call of Duty 2.
Call of Duty, du bist 14, darfst du eigentlich auch noch nicht spielen?
Ja, ich weiß. Ja genau, dazu wollte ich auch noch was sagen, dann gleich. Okay, dieses Call of Duty 2 ist ab 18 erstmal, falls jemand da ist, der das nicht weiß, ab wie vieler da ist. Und da ist eigentlich so, ich hatte irgendwie mal einen Gutschein bekommen und da hab ich mir mal gedacht, den löse ich da mal ein. Bin mit meinem Vater zum Mediamarkt gegangen und dann hab ich das da gesehen. Ich hab da auch schon mal eine Demo von gespielt, die kann man sich ja überall runterladen im Internet, kostenlos. Und dann hat er mir das halt geholt. Aber das ist halt auch wieder so eine Marktlücke, also nicht Marktlücke, sondern eher so eine Lücke bei dem FSK und dem ganzen Altersdreigarm und so.
Was für eine Lücke?
Naja, dass man halt die Fragen halt nicht nach, für wen das ist. Da kann man, kann der Erwachsener eigentlich kaufen, was er will. Für Personen, die 10 Jahre alt sind, da kann er Spiel ab 18 kaufen und alles Mögliche.
Achso, du meinst, dein Vater geht das an der Kasse kaufen und die fragen ihn nicht, wollen sie das spielen oder ihre Kinder?
Genau, das ist halt oft ein Problem.
Das würde ich nicht sagen. Ich denke mal, da spielt die Verantwortung der Eltern eine Rolle. Und ich glaube, Verkäufer sollte sich nicht ermächtigen, einem Elternteil, ob deinem Vater oder deiner Mutter, jetzt diese Verantwortung abzusprechen.
Ich würde das auch als Freiheit empfinden, wenn ich ein Spiel kaufe und der mich fragt, für wen ist das? Das geht denen einfach mal überhaupt nichts an. Ihm geht irgendwie an, ob ich die Altersfreigabe erfülle, ob ich also dann 18 bin oder älter. Und mehr hat ihn eigentlich schon nichts zu interessieren.
Im Zweifelsfall, also solltest du mit deinem Vater dahingehen und quasi du legst das Spiel auf den Tisch und dein Papa legt den Fuffi auf den Tisch, dann kann der Verkäufer schon mal sagen, sie wissen schon, dass das ab 18 ist. Aber ansonsten geht das glaube ich ein bisschen weiter. Dann müsste in dem Fall eher dein Vater sich mal fragen lassen, warum er dir Spiele gibt, die ab 18 zugelassen sind. Hat dein Papa mal geguckt, was das für ein Spiel ist?
Ja, das hat er sich gründlich angeguckt und dann musste ich auch noch mit ihm diskutieren und so.
Was waren die Diskussionsgründe, Punkte?
Naja, er hat halt nicht so ein gutes Verhältnis zu schießen.
Was nachvollziehbar ist.
Genau, das kann ich auch verstehen, aber im Echtleben Menschen umbringen, das ist jetzt... Da sagen die meisten immer, ich bringe ihn um und dann laufen sie auch mal. Aber irgendwie ist das bei anderen Menschen...
Nein, nein.
Also Menschen umbringen, das ist überhaupt nicht.
Nee, danke, das würde ich niemals machen.
Aber worauf habt ihr euch jetzt geeinigt? Dein Vater hat gesagt, auf Leute schießen ist Unsinn, Schmarn, Blödsinn, was auch immer er gesagt hat, und du spielst es aber trotzdem. Also müsst ihr ja einen Konsens gefunden haben.
Ja, wir haben sozusagen ausgemacht, dass es halt... Naja, ich hab ihm dann halt ein bisschen was darüber erklärt.
Was waren denn deine Argumente?
Also meine Argumente waren halt, dass man nicht wahllos irgendwelche Personen umlietet, sondern das ist halt auch, wie schon gesagt, mit Taktik auch.
Weil das ist nicht einfach nur Bam-Bam. Weil sonst ist man sofort weg.
Weil die anderen schneller Bam-Bam gemacht haben, oder?
Nee, wir waren beim Argument, was du gegenüber deinem Vater hattest.
Genau, also erstmal, dass es taktisch ist und dass es nicht wahlloses Rumgeballere ist. Und dann das zweite Argument war auch noch, weil nach einer Zeit ist irgendwie alles nicht mehr so aktuell. Und das Spiel war dann halt, weil ich das unbedingt haben wollte.
Also im Endeffekt hast du so lange gequengelt, bis er entnervt gesagt hat, mach doch.
Nein, also er hat nicht gesagt, mach doch. Dann haben wir uns halt geeinigt, dass ich dann bestimmte Arbeiten auf eine bestimmte Zeit machen muss.
Wie, ihr habt euch darauf geeinigt, dass du dieses Spiel spielen kannst und dafür musst du das Auto waschen oder so?
Oder Hause füttern?
Staubsaugen, Müll runterbringen, Katze füttern? Alter, ist nicht wahr.
Ist ja geil.
Hat dein Vater das Spiel gespielt?
Ja, er hat mir mal dabei zugeguckt.
Aber sag mal, Frederik, ist doch eigentlich total cool, wie das gelaufen ist, oder? Also soll das nicht genau so laufen? Also jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass ihr dauernd Spiele spielt, hier bei 18 sind, aber ist doch eigentlich ein ganz schöner Prozess. Er hat sich Zeit für dich genommen, ihr habt das gemeinsam diskutiert, du musst das argumentieren. Und muss jetzt regelmäßig das Auto waschen.
Naja, regelmäßig.
Das hat sich jetzt schon erledigt.
Ich meine, wärst du dir am Nachhinein lieber gewesen, er hätt's dir einfach gekauft und du hättest es gespielt? Oder fandest du es über den Weg ganz okay?
Ja, und dann wollte ich eigentlich noch was sagen. Die Zeitschriften werden ja auch überall verkauft und da achtet auch kein Verkäufer eigentlich drauf.
Du meinst, die Computer einfach gemacht und so? Entschuldigung, ich mach mal den Mikrofon auf.
Die Demos, die dann dabei gelegt sind, die sind das Problem, oder?
Da bin ich mir allerdings nicht sicher, ob die wirklich so ungeprüft auf den Markt kommen. Ich glaube, da gibt es bei den Zeitschriften inzwischen einfach verschiedene Versionen. Dass du eben dann nicht komplette Demo-Versionen hast oder eine abgespeckte Version ab 16.
Also ich kenne es von meinen Heavy-Metal-Zeitungen, die ich immer kaufe. Da steht immer drin, der Inhalt dieser Zeitschrift ist nicht jugendbeeinträchtigend. Oder der CD oder so. Das steht da explizit drauf, damit der Verkäufer sich darüber im Klaren ist, dass er da keine Dinge verkauft, für die er benannt werden kann.
Jetzt noch mal ganz kurzer Einschub bei Amazon. Zu der Amazon-Geschichte ist es also ein technisches Problem, weil man kann der Post nicht mitteilen, was sie genau prüfen sollte. Sie können nur sagen, ok, 18 oder nicht. Aber es gibt da keine Einstufungen weiter.
Die können dich ab 16 oder ab 12 prüfen. Die können nur erwachsen oder nicht erwachsen.
Ja, genau, das wurde mir gerade so schriftlich per mail berichtet.
Aber interessant, da können wir ja trotzdem noch mal nachfragen. Das ist trotzdem eine interessante These. Frederik, danke für den Anruf. Und viel Spaß bei der nächsten Diskussion mit deinem Papa. Kinder, die Leitung brummt. Wir werden wahrscheinlich heute nicht alle Leute rankriegen. Der nächste am Telefon, der schon ganz doll lange wartet, ist Jörg aus Kamin. Hallo, Jörg.
Ja, einen wunderschönen Abend.
Die erste Frage, wo ist Kamin?
Das ist nicht Kamin, das ist Kamen, Kreis Unanahe, Dortmund.
Ah, okay, also klar.
Ja, da wartet auch ein Kollege, Miro, der kommt auch später noch, der kann das vielleicht noch ein bisschen näher erklären.
Kamen, das Berg Kamen, die Ecke irgendwo.
Ja, genau.
Du bist 23.
Genau, ich bin 23. Ich bin eigentlich, ja, man hat mir fast schon all meine Argumente genommen. Ich bin ziemlich begeistert, was die Vorredner, gerade die Jüngeren bisher alles gesagt haben. Das bestätigt eigentlich auch nur meine These. Ich finde es absoluten ausgemacht, ein Quatsch, dass man über Killerspiele und so ein riesen Premorium macht. Ich denke, das wird mir, ich hoffe, es wird mir nicht böse nachher auch noch mal erwähnen, es ist wohl auch bestätigt worden, dass alle, oder dass die ganzen Amokläufer, die da halt mit in diese Argumentation reingebracht werden, dass die überdurchschnittlich schlau waren, dass sie also nicht blöd waren. Ich persönlich bin der absolut festen Überzeugung, dass das, ich sag mal, immens viel mit der Aufklärung zu tun hat. Ich selbst bin Vater von einer kleinen Tochter und natürlich mach ich mir darüber auch Gedanken. Oder auch darauf hin schon einige Male angesprochen, weil ich halt auch sehr viel mit EDV zu tun hab. Und ich denke, dass es genauso wie jetzt das bei meinem Vorredner gelaufen ist, genauso bin ich der Meinung, sollte es laufen, dass zumindest, dass man die Zeit nimmt, dass man Initiative zeigt und dass man sich auch ein bisschen damit beschäftigt. Natürlich wird man nicht alles auseinandernehmen können bis ins kleinste Detail, aber ich bin schon der Meinung, dass das Kinder und gerade die Jüngeren verstehen sollten, worum es da geht und dass das halt nicht echt ist oder so. Aber ich bin absolut nicht der Meinung, dass es Aggressivität fördert.
Thorsten hat gerade einen Einwurf.
Ja, das eben gesagt, dass die Diskussion so ein bisschen überflüssig sei oder zumindest fasse ich das mal jetzt so grob zusammen. Ich stimme dir zu, die ist auf jeden Fall viel zu aufgeregt und auch viel zu reflexartig immer. Aber kannst du dir trotzdem ein bisschen was abgewinnen? Also hältst du sie für überflüssig oder kannst du auch schon verstehen, dass Diskussionen auftauchen? In Bezug auf Killerspiele oder die sogenannten Killerspiele, Ego-Shooter oder ähnliches?
Also in Bezug auf Killerspiele kann ich es in keinster Weise verstehen. Weil ich bin mehr und mehr der Meinung, dass einfach, ich weiß jetzt leider nicht mehr, wie die Frau vorhin hieß, die angerufen hat. Antje. Antje, dass das einfach auch ein Stück weit an der Gesellschaft liegt. Also ich habe diese Diskussion nicht von Anfang an verfolgt, hier Erfurt und so. Aber ich habe eben mitbekommen, dass das von dem Typen, der da eben ausgerastet ist, mehrfach bekannt war, dass der eben mit Waffen irgendwie durch den Fett gelaufen ist oder da in irgendeinem Bunker da rumgehaust hat und so. Und da stelle ich mir dann einfach die Frage, warum kriegt man sowas mit und reagiert nicht darauf. Warum wussten die Eltern nichts davon, bzw. warum haben sie da nicht eingegriffen? Das ist für mich absolute Fahrlächtigkeit. Da gehören dann die Eltern dementsprechend zur Rechenschaft gezogen. Das würde ich mir persönlich auch nie verzeihen, wenn ich sage, meine Tochter ist jetzt 16 und kommt da mit irgendwelchen Klamotten um die Ecke. Und das hat Konsequenzen dann für sie. Also ich sag mal, dass sie dann anfängt, Leute abzuschlachten oder so. Da würde ich an mir selbst zweifeln. Da würde ich wirklich sagen, okay, da hast du was nicht mitgekriegt, warst du nicht aufmerksam genug oder sonst irgendetwas. Es ist immer sehr einfach, das dann auf so Banalitäten, die schon ewig und drei Tage da waren, also Killerspiele abzuschieben. Killerspiele waren schon immer da und auch irgendwelche Skispiele, und die kann man ja jetzt...
Und auch die Diskussion darüber, dass man sagt, die Gesellschaft ist schuld oder die Politik ist schuld, man muss sich darum kümmern und man kehrt in dem Moment weder in seinem eigenen Garten noch vor seiner eigenen Tür und fragt sich, habe ich mich jemals dafür interessiert, was meine Zwerge eigentlich in ihrem Kinderzimmer so machen, wenn die Tür zu ist.
Ganz genau.
Du hast von Miro erzählt, wir nehmen jetzt noch Miro an die Leitung und wollt ihr noch auch schnell Hallo sagen?
Wir können uns auch gerne Hallo sagen.
Hallo Miro. Ey, von Una zu Una über Babelsberg, das möchte man sich mal bitte kurz geografisch vorstellen.
Klein und dann passt das schon.
Gut Jungs, ihr könnt dann später noch miteinander euch Nettigkeiten austauschen. Danke Jörg.
Ja, kein Problem. Ich danke euch.
Miro, was hast du zuzufügen?
Jörg hat das ja richtig gut schon reingebracht. Das ist irgendwie so eine Diskussion. Das hat ja alles hier so Richtung Politiker angefangen. Da ist ja was passiert. Das Kind ist in den Brunnen gefallen und dann dachte man sich, ja, wo ist der Grund? Irgendwie, ich hab wohl schon mal so ein paar Leute kennengelernt, die so ein bisschen drauf sind. Also jetzt kein Armokläufer oder sowas.
Was meinst du mit so ein bisschen drauf?
Kannst du das präzisieren? Die, ich sag mal, die auf diese Spiele so ein bisschen komisch reagieren.
Also die das doof finden oder die es bedenklich finden. Oder die dadurch die Spiele aggressiv werden und dadurch animiert werden.
Wo ich mir immer so ein bisschen Sorgen mache, ich möchte nicht unbedingt sofort, also den ganzen Tag in deren Nähe sein. Weil das Problem ist doch, das hat doch alles immer einen Hintergrund. Zum Beispiel jetzt die Sache mit Erfurt. Der Typ wurde irgendwie, ich glaub, von den Leuten meistens gehändelt oder so, von seinen Klassenkameraden. Das hat sich dann irgendwie aufgebaut und ich glaube, das war sowieso bei jedem von den Leuten.
Also die Probleme von Steinhäusern waren nochmal umfassender. Also es ging nicht nur um Hänseleien. Hänseleien reicht noch glaube ich nicht aus.
Durch die Prüfung geflogen.
Und dann nicht mehr zugelassen worden, genau.
Und wenn dann irgendwie so rein zufällig der Vater mal wieder im Schützensverein ist, ich glaube, das war auch fast bei jedem der Fall, dass die irgendwie ziemlich leicht an die Knacken gekommen sind. Da macht sich aber natürlich keiner der Politiker Gedanken drüber so. Und irgendwo ist diese Diskussion über diese Ballerspiele recht albern. Ich meine, ich hab früher Duden gespielt, das hat mir auch nichts getan.
Na ja, pass auf, aber trotz alledem wird ja diskutiert, gerade jetzt im Moment wird wieder darüber diskutiert, der Kultusminister und auch in Bayern kommt immer wieder der Vorschlag, es müssen solche Videos verboten werden, solche Spiele müssen verboten werden und im Allgemeinen ist das alles viel zu lax. Und die Jugendlichen sind alle gefährdet. Du hast gerade angeführt, dass die gerne immer wieder an dem Punkt herangenommenen Argumente der Amokläufe in Emstetten und in Erfurt, dass die relativ wenig mit Spielen zu tun haben, dass sich keiner mit den Personen beschäftigt hat, die die Täter waren. Aber trotz alledem ist diese Diskussion ja da und deswegen diskutieren wir ja auch heute darüber, wie das jetzt mit dem ach so laxen Jugendschutz in Deutschland eigentlich ist, wie die Praxis aussieht und was man da jetzt praktisch ändern kann.
Sicher, aber man kann jetzt nicht nur die ganze Zeit über die Spiele reden. Ich denke mal, dass die Spiele nur ein Teil davon sind. Was vielleicht wichtiger ist, sind die Leute, die die Reaktion von den Leuten, wie sie das aufnehmen. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt, ganz ehrlich, ich hab kein Problem damit, wenn ein 14-jähriger Counter-Strike spielt. Hab ich kein Problem mit. Nur wenn diese Person, ich sag mal ganz dreist, wenn diese Person labil ist, so was nicht verkraften kann. Oder hinterher merkt, verdammt, die Leute haben mich geärgert. Mein Vater hat auch eine Knarre, dann mach ich das mal schon mal weg. Meine Probleme, das ist das Schlimme.
Aber meinst du denn, man kann tatsächlich abschätzen, welche langfristigen Auswirkungen sowas auf Jugendliche auch hat, so einen Einfluss von Spielen. Das heißt, wenn du es einfach gewohnt bist, jeden Tag zwei Stunden auf Menschen zu schießen, egal ob es jetzt Pixel-Menschen sind, dass es einfach so diese Abstumpfungseffekte da ist. Glaubst du nicht, dass es nicht auch eine Rolle spielen könnte?
Ja, das kommt halt wieder auf diese Person an. Ich meine, ich kann bestimmt auch zwei Stunden jeden Tag spielen, wenn ich die Zeit hätte und mir wird das auch nicht wirklich was tun. Es ist gut, es könnte unter Umständen sein, es kommt vielleicht darauf an, mit was für einem Alter man anfängt. Weil, wenn man ja irgendwie jünger ist, na, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ich glaube, dass es viel einfacher ist. Man kann sich auch nicht, anstatt zu sagen, es ist für Jugendliche zugänglich oder nicht, kann man auch nicht sagen, das ist mit 11, 12, 13 oder 14. Da gibt es eine Grenze, wo ein Schalter umgelegt wird, Leute können so etwas verkraften. Viel eher müssen sich die Leute, die im direkten Umfeld sind, Gedanken machen, was da um sie herum passiert. Und nicht nur sagen, da muss sich der Lehrer darum kümmern, wenn die Eltern es sagen. Oder die Lehrer sagen, ich habe andere Sachen zu tun, dann müssen sich die Eltern darum kümmern. Wenn Lehrer und Eltern es nicht schaffen, sagen sie beide, da muss sich der Staat darum kümmern. Der Ball wird immer von einer Hälfte in die andere gespielt und keiner ist wirklich bereit, dazu Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Ich glaube, da sind wir an dem Punkt, über den wir heute noch diskutieren werden. Annette hat noch einen Einruf und dann sind wir schon über die Nachrichten, es gibt Ärger.
Ich glaube auch, dass der Jugendmedienschutz, wie er momentan in Deutschland existiert, nicht darauf ausgerichtet ist, Kinder und Jugendliche davor zu schützen oder zu bewahren, Amok zu laufen, sondern ganz klar eigentlich dafür da ist, sie vor bestimmten Inhalten zu schützen. Wie zum Beispiel Sechsjährige vor zu krasser Gewalt.
Sechsjährige, klar.
Das nehme ich auch so, ist auch so vernünftig. Aber hier allein dieser Begriff Ballerspiele, das ist einfach nur albern.
Da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht.
Das wurde, glaube ich, von euch auch mal ziemlich gut beschrieben. Das ist einfach nur eine Diskussion, die von Politikern angefangen wurde und wo Berater waren, die den Leuten mal in zwei Minuten erklärt haben, worum es da geht. Und die haben einfach keine Ahnung.
Danke für den Anruf, Miro. Hui, die Leitungen sind voll. Wir haben noch eine Menge zu diskutieren. Philipps noch dran, Sven, Jan, Erik, Axel ist auch noch da. Wir wollen auch noch mit Herrn Brüning reden. Herr Brüning ist... Frank, der hat dir eine Mail geschrieben. Der ist Wissenschaftler. Pass auf, wir erklären einfach Nachrichten. Bleiben Sie dran, Herr Brüning.
Wie hieß der erste deutsche Fernsehsender? Ist es so, ja?
Ja.
Ich glaube auch, der zweite? Nennen wir mal 5 dritte Programme.
5 dritte, WDR, RBB und natürlich noch Bayern 3.
Ja, das sind 3?
9 von 7 Deutschen können nicht richtig zählen. Sind aber trotzdem gern dabei. Das Fritz-Kneipen-Quiz. Jede Woche, Donnerstag, woanders. Morgen Abend im Oranke am See. Berlin Hohenschönhausen. Aber immer ab 22 Uhr. Mit Tommy Wosch. Michi Balzer.
Ich hab mich immer davon aus, oder?
Und Fritz-Kneipen-Quiz-Master Thomas Vogel. Das Fritz-Kneipen-Quiz.
Und das hört man.
Fünf nach halb zwölf.
Mit Grisha Zedelke. Der bisherige britische Premierminister Blair ist zum neuen Sondergesandten des Neust Quartetts anhand worden. Das gab die UNO in New York bekannt. In seiner neuen Funktion soll Blair die Friedensbemühungen zwischen Israelis und Palästinensern wiederbeleben. Vorrangig ist dabei die Suche nach einer Zwei-Staaten-Lösung. Blair hatte das Amt des Regierungschefs am Nachmittag nach 10 Jahren aufgegeben. Anschließend wurde sein Nachfolger Gordon Brown mit der Regierungsbildung beauftragt. Im Radsport gibt es offenbar einen neuen Dopingfall. Matthias Kessler, langjähriger Helfer von Jan Ulrich und Andreas Klöden wurde im April positiv auf Testosteron getestet. Das gab sein Rennstall Astana bekannt. Kessler wurde zunächst bis zum Ergebnis der B-Probe suspendiert. Er war fest für die am 7. Juli beginnende Tour de France eingeplant. Die Bundesregierung hatte ein neues Förderprogramm für Langzeitarbeitslose beschlossen. Arbeitsminister Müntefering stellte im Kabinett einen sogenannten Kommunal-Kombilohn vor. Der Bund will danach Anfang 2008 für einen Zeitraum von drei Jahren die Hälfte des Lohns übernehmen, wenn Kommunen oder Wohlfahrtsverbände Langzeitarbeitslose für bestimmte Tätigkeiten zusätzlich anstellen. Das Neuförderprogramm soll für alle Regionen gelten, in denen die Arbeitslosenquote mehr als 15 Prozent beträgt. Bahnchef Medon bleibt bis 2011 im Amt. Der Aufsichtsrat des Unternehmens teilte nach einer Sitzung mit, dass der Vertrag des 64-Jährigen um drei Jahre verlängert werde. Damit kann Medon die geplante Privatisierung der Bahn weiter vorantreiben. Der Bundestag hat im November grundsätzlich entschieden, das letzte große Staatsunternehmen in Deutschland bis 2009 in Teilen an die Börse zu bringen. In der Nacht wird der Wind weniger und der Regen lässt nach. Es kühlt ab auf 12 bis 9 Grad. Am Tag bleibt es wechselhaft bei 17 bis 19 Grad. Der Verkehr fritzt an. 19 Wittstockdosse Richtung Rostock zwischen dem Dreieck Wittstockdoss und Waren. Eine Müröz ist ein Schwertransport unterwegs, der nicht überholt werden kann. Und dann immer noch die A10, nördlicher Wiener Ring, Hafenland Richtung Schwarnenbeck. Zwischen Mühlenbeck und dem Dreieck Pankow besteht Gefahr durch einen defekten LKW. Der rechte Fahrstreifen ist gesperrt. Und wir haben recherchiert, der ist nicht vom ADAC dort abgestellt worden.
Wartet.
Der wartet.
Ich hab jetzt auf deine gute Fahrt gewartet.
Ja, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Und wir sehen uns dann bald wieder. Jugendschutz ist das Thema im Chaos Radio Teil 125 auf Fritz, letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, schönen guten Abend. Frank, Annett und Thorsten vom Chaos Computer Club sind auch hier. Wir haben jetzt fast anderthalb Stunden über Computerspiele geredet. Es gab bei uns auf dem Fritz Board, weil die Leitungen sind wirklich extrem voll und nicht alle kommen durch. Das tut uns zwar leid, aber ihr könnt gerne auf dem Fritz Board oder beim Chaos Radio im Chat weitermachen, mitdiskutieren. Gab es den durchaus berechtigten Einwurf, jetzt haben ganz viele Leute gesagt, es gibt schon einen Unterschied zwischen taktischen Spielen wie Counterstrike und bloßem Abschießen von Leuten. Und der Einwurf, der durchaus diskussionswürdig ist, war, wo ist da der Unterschied, ob es jetzt taktisch ist oder nicht. Es geht darum, irgendwie Leute kalt zu machen, Pixel hin oder her. Es ist eine Gewaltdarstellung, eine Gewaltverherrlichung und eine Art und Weise, die natürlich vom Spieler selbst ausgeht, die er selbst auslöst. Und da sollte man das nicht kleiner reden, als es eigentlich ist. Diskutiert damit 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste am Telefon ist Christoph aus Siegen. Guten Abend, Christoph. Du kommst quasi von der anderen Seite die Straße lang. Du bist Student auf Lehramt und beschäftigst dich von Berufswegen mit dem Thema.
Ja, was heißt von Berufswegen? Also es hat sich irgendwann die Möglichkeit ergeben, dass ich meine Abschlussarbeit, wir müssen so eine Startsarbeit schreiben, neben den ganzen Prüfungen, Examen, dass ich diese Arbeit über Computerspiele auch schreiben kann. Ja, und also eigentlich habe ich die mehr über Computerspielen zu Kindern und Jugendliteratur geschrieben, also Harry Potter, TKKG und so was.
Also Computerspiele, die sich quasi mit solchen Büchern beschäftigen.
Genau, oder die halt in diesem Themenumfeld irgendwie angesiedelt sind. Ich habe mich natürlich auch in dieser Kielerspieldebatte dann erstmal im Rahmen meiner Startsabit auseinandergesetzt und dann wurde das nachher zu so einem Hobby, dass ich mich echt gefragt habe, was geht da ab bei den Leuten? Also ich habe irgendwie zuerst gedacht, gut, das sind die Politiker, die schießen irgendwelche Sachen raus, wie sie das immer machen und habe aber dann angefangen, das kann ja nicht alles sein. Ich habe dann mit Lehrern gesprochen, mit Pädagogieprofessoren, mit Psychologieprofessoren, mit allen möglichen Leuten, um mal dahinter zu kommen, warum die Leute jetzt alle nach diesem Verbot schreien.
Und du hast auch mit Politikern gesprochen?
Ja, genau.
Und?
Ja, gut, was soll ich sagen. Also die erwartbaren Reaktionen. Je weiter links man irgendwie im politischen Farbespektrum kommt, desto verneiner werden die Antworten, was das Verbot angeht. Und je weiter rechts oder mittig man sich bewegt, desto mehr wird nach diesem Verbot gejammert.
Und wie begründen die Leute dieses Verbot? Warum sind sie davon überzeugt, dass das wirklich sinnvoll ist?
Das geht so von ganz allen Seiten. Wenn wir das Verbot haben, gibt es keine Armhaukläufe mehr. Da brauchen wir gar nicht so mal reden über so eine Argumentation. Bis zu so Sachen, wir brauchen das unbedingt, weil der bisherige Jugendlichenschutz nicht funktioniert. Und die Leute sind völlig immun. Ich habe da wirklich teilweise über mehrere Stunden mit den Leuten diskutiert und denen klar gemacht, nicht der Jugendschutz ist das Problem, sondern wie wir den zurzeit angehen ist das Problem. Und wie die Leute vielleicht mitfehlen, dass Lehrer, Eltern, dass sie keine Medienkompetenz haben.
Wie kann das denn...
Also Medienkompetenz finde ich ist genau das richtige Schlagwort. Also dass man halt gerade an Schulen und Erziehungs- und Bildungseinrichtungen mehr in Richtung Sozialkompetenz, Lesekompetenz und Medienkompetenz unterrichten oder lehren sollte.
Ich glaube der Ansatz von Christoph klang eben so ein bisschen anders als müssten erstmal die Lehrer auch Medienkompetenz sein.
Ohne Frage.
Also gut, also das ist halt die Sache. Wenn ich Güte unterrichten will, muss ich Güte kennen. Ich muss zumindest so was damit auskennen, dass ich es glaubhaft unterrichten kann. Und wenn ich mich so in meinem Umfeld umgucke, ich möchte nicht über meine ganzen Kommilitonen irgendwie rumrenten und die irgendwie alle über einen Kamm scheren. Aber ich sehe da zwei Arten von Leuten. Die einen mögen Killerspiele, die anderen mögen sie nicht und alle zusammen haben eigentlich keine differenziertere Meinung darüber hinaus. Viele haben die Spiele gar nicht gespielt. Und viele wollen sich auch überhaupt nicht damit beschäftigen, selbst wenn man denen sagt, eure Schüler spielen das nachher, ihr müsst das kennen, einfach um zu wissen, wie wir darauf reagieren müssen. Das wird dann einfach abgewiegelt. Nee, nee, das ist ja alles schlecht und die Politiker machen das verboten, dann ist für uns die Sache gegessen.
Aber was glaubst du denn, was ist denn das Ziel davon, wenn diese Medienkompetenz erst mal da ist, dass die Jugendlichen die Spiele nicht mehr spielen, weil sie sie denn blöd finden, aus welchen Gründen? Oder dass sie die zwar spielen, aber ich sag mal, ja, verstehen, reflektieren, Abstand davon gewinnen. So. Also was ist denn da das Ziel davon, wenn sie denn medienkompetenter werden?
Also ich würde mir, ja anders. Wir haben bei vielen anderen Sachen, können wir den Schülern irgendwelche Entscheidungskompetenzen mit an die Hand geben. Wir können ihnen erklären, wie man urteilt, ob etwas gut oder etwas schlecht für einen ist. Und das passt viel sicher. Wir wissen zum Beispiel von unserem Biologieunterricht her, dass sie was gegen Eis tun müssen. Und dass irgendwie Rechtsextremismus auch sehr schlecht ist. Aber bei dieser Medienkompetenzgeschichte würde es eigentlich erstmal darum gehen, den Schülern überhaupt mal klar zu machen, die Dinger sind nicht einfach nur irgendwas für die Freizeit, sondern die kann man auch bewerten. Also ich würde gar nicht so weit gehen und sagen wollen, dass sie dann alle aufhören zu spielen, bloß weil wir denen erklärt haben, dass das Mist ist. Darüber will ich ja gar nicht hinaus. Aber um das nochmal von der anderen Seite anzugehen, ein großes Problem ist, dass man meistens, wenn man über dieses Killerspielverbot spricht, man hat diese Spiele im Kopf. Und wenn ich mit den Leuten gesprochen habe, haben die mir gesagt, ja, man hat mir gezeigt, wie da Menschen abgeschlachtet werden. Und ich hab dann gefragt, hatten sie das denn auch mal gespielt? Ja nee, mir hat das ja gereicht, wie man das gesehen hat, wie die da abgeschlachtet wurden. Und es ist einfach ein ganz krasser Unterschied bei Computerspielen, ob man teilnimmt, ob man spielt oder ob man nicht spielt. Denn was man da wahrnimmt, wenn man nicht spielt, ist ein Gesamtbild. Und wenn man da spielt, ist man da ganz anders involviert. Und dann tosiert man sich vielleicht gar nicht für das Toten, sondern irgendwie für das Spielen an sich, was man da gerade an Bewegung ausführt.
Darüber gibt es auch durchaus psychologische und wissenschaftliche Studien. Das war in der letzten Sendung zum Thema quasi auch fast eine halbe Stunde lang ein Gesprächswert, dass ein Psychologe das quasi per Hirnstrom und per Analyse untersucht hat, was passiert, wenn man das selber spielt, welche Reflexe und Reaktionen angesprochen werden und wie das aussieht, wenn man nur zuguckt. Also quasi, Schrägstrich, das im Fernsehen in einem Beitrag sieht und dann denkt, das ist die Wirklichkeit. Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Baustellen, hast du recht.
Jaja, und was das andere ist, ich hab mich dann auch wirklich mit einem Psychologieprofessor mal hingesetzt und gefragt. Also ich hab mir diese Studie besorgt, die als Grundlage genommen haben, um das Kielerspielverbot im Koalitionsvertrag zu verankern. Und also das ist peinlich. Das ist wirklich peinlich und das sage nicht ich, sondern das hat der Psychologieprofessor. Ich kann da jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen über abziehen. Da wird ein Datenbestand genommen von angloamerikanischen Jugendlichen im Alter von 14 bis 17 Jahren, von 1950 bis 1975 über das Fernsehverhalten von diesen jungen Menschen und erklärt, warum wir jetzt ein Kielerspielverbot brauchen. Das ist kein Witz.
Weißt du, wer dahinter steckt, Christoph?
Ha, Lukasch, der ist, glaube ich, das ist jetzt Universität Regensburg, da müsste ich gerade selber nochmal googeln.
Lukasch hat so eine undifferenzierte Studie veröffentlicht?
Kennst du, Entschuldigung, du guckst so, wissen kennst du den, kannst du was dazu sagen?
Nee, das wäre jetzt wieder gefährliches Halbwissen, aber Lukasch wäre mir noch nicht auffällig geworden in dem Bereich. Deswegen bin ich verwundert.
Also vor allem in Unionsnähe, was da an Papieren irgendwie erstellt wird, hat Lukasch auffällig häufig irgendwie eine Studie dazu gemacht. Also die Sache ist, die Meinpsychologie-Prof hat da wieder gesagt, irgendwie das ist gut noch, das ist schlecht. Der hat einfach gesagt, wer momentan behauptet, da gibt es irgendwie einen Zusammenhang, der lübt ganz einfach, weil die Forschung ist noch nicht so weit.
Es gibt keine empirischen Evidenzen, keine Zuhörungen. Es gibt noch keine Studie, die überzeugend gewesen wäre. Genau.
Selbst wenn die wollen würden, sie könnten momentan noch nichts sagen. Und das ist jetzt ein Problem, das müssten die Politiker ganz alleine aussitzen, wie sie dieses gesellschaftliche Problem lösen. Menschen, die an den Rand der Gesellschaft gedrängt wurden, die ins Soziale ausgedrängt wurden, die über Jahre hinweg keiner ernst oder überhaupt nur wahrgenommen hat, die müssen jetzt irgendwie entweder in die Gesellschaft zurückgeholt werden oder sonst irgendwie muss versucht werden, mit diesem Umstand jetzt klarzukommen.
Du hast ja selber eben schon einen ganz guten Anspruch auch entworfen, dass jemand, der mit Jugendlichen oder Kindern zu tun hat, selber auch die Erfahrung vorweisen muss, eben zum Beispiel als Lehramtskandidat oder später als Lehrer. Wie sehen deine Erfahrungen aus und zwar auch unabhängig von Spielen? Also bist du auch fit im Bereich Musik und Filme? Bist du auch auf dem Level der Jugendlichen? Kannst du mit denen auf einer Augenhöhe diskutieren und reden?
Das weiß ich gar nicht. Das müsste man, glaube ich, mal auf bestimmte Gruppen von Schülern loslassen. Also mein Musikgeschmack ist gänzlich an der heutigen Jugend vorbei, schätze ich einfach mal. Die Frage ist nicht, ob ich irgendwie das höre, was die Jugendlichen hören. Das glaube ich einfach nicht. Aber ich muss mich darauf einlassen können.
Also du wirst bereit, dich auch mal mit Bushido oder Sido auseinanderzusetzen, wenn das Thema wird.
Wobei Bushido und Sido natürlich ganz schön 2004 ist, wa?
Wenn ich von vornherein sage, ich kenne einige solche Leute in meinem Kommunitorenumfeld, die sagen, ich will mit diesen Spielen nichts zu tun haben, dann hab ich denen gesagt, ihr habt ein Problem, wenn eure Schüler das machen. Ihr könnt nicht einfach sagen, das ist schlecht, wenn ihr es nicht kennt. Ihr könnt es nicht. Das könnt ihr auch nicht bei Goethe machen.
Aber was sagst du denn möglicherweise zu einem Abstumpfungseffekt, der dich durch diese Computerspiele ergibt oder auch insgesamt durch Mediennutzung, wo jetzt Inhalte gezeigt werden, die jetzt auch geregelt werden sollen oder geregelt werden derzeit. Also es ist ja auch schwierig, immer nur von diesen Extremfällen, von irgendwelchen Armokläufen zu reden, sondern es findet ja insgesamt auch eine Wirkung von den Medien auf Jugendliche statt. Und glaubst du denn, dass das auch völlig abwegig ist oder würdest du dem schon zustimmen, dass es da eine gewisse Wirkung gibt auf Jugendliche?
Also, wenn man eine bestimmte Sache sehr häufig macht, dann verliert sie womöglich in Reiz und man wird abgestumpft ihr gegenüber. Und wenn ich relativ häufig sehr gewalttätige Computerspiele konsumiere, dann werde ich wahrscheinlich gegenüber dieser Form, also dieses Mitspielens von digitaler Gewalt unter Umständen, ich kann das nicht belegen, ich habe auch bisher keine empirischen Beweise dafür gefunden, dann werde ich vielleicht abgestumpft. Das ist aber nur gegen diese Form.
Im Zweifelsfall gibt es dann irgendwann zu dem Spiel ein Update und die Grafik ist besser, man kann sich daran wieder festbeißen.
Ja, die Grafik nicht, aber vielleicht ist irgendwann, kommen die doch mal auf die Idee, mal ein besseres Gameplay zu machen oder irgendwie mal da was anderes zu machen und dann gewinnt dieses Medium wieder an Reiz.
Aber sagen wir, vielleicht nehmen wir auch mal Filme mit dazu. Oder generell, was im Netz an Medien zu sehen ist. Also hauptsächlich Fotos, Videos, Filme. Da werden ja auch Sachen gezeigt, sei es ob Frauen geschlagen werden oder was auch immer. Ja, wie denkst du das? Gibt es da einen Grund, das zu regulieren oder?
Ja, gut, wir haben ja schon einen Jugendschutz, einen sehr harten, eigentlich den strengsten der selbst. Und an dem hat es bisher auch nicht gemangelt, an den Jugendschutzgesetzen hat es ja bisher nicht gemangelt, an der Umsetzung hat es tatsächlich gemangelt. Also es gibt Filme, die ich meinen Kindern nicht ohne Begleitung zeigen möchte, es gibt Filme, die ich meinen Kindern am liebsten, wenn ich jetzt welche hätte, oder meinen Schülern auch nachher bis zu einem gewissen Alter überhaupt nicht zeigen möchte. Es gibt auch Computerspiele, die ich einfach bei meinen Schülern nicht sehen möchte am liebsten, aber genauso gibt es auch Bücher. Das ist aber jetzt die Frage, ob sie das einfach alles konsumieren können, wie sie es wollen. Welche Reife ich ihnen schon anerkenne. Also diese Sachen mit den Altersangaben ist eine witzige Hilfe, aber mehr auch nicht. Also ich kenne durchaus 12-Jährige, die bereit sind, Medien ab 18 zu konsumieren. Und ich kenne durchaus 18-Jährige, denen man sie immer noch nicht in die Hand geben sollte.
Würde denn dieses differenzierte System wie das PEGI-System, würde das deiner Meinung nach was bringen? Dass also die Eltern schon eher begreifen und das nicht nur als so eine Formalien sehen.
Dass auf den Artikeln quasi kleine so Piktogramme drauf sind, auf denen drauf steht, erhält Gewalt, enthält Drogen, enthält Nacktheit, so was, dass man genauer weiß, worum es geht.
Ich habe mich da jetzt noch ehrlich gesagt nicht so mit auseinandergesetzt, aber ich würde mir so eine Plakette wünschen, wie enthält die Notwendigkeit der Partizipation der Eltern.
Das versteht ja wieder keiner.
Ja klar, das versteht keiner. Gut, das hätte natürlich einen Vorteil, wenn ich es möglichst kompliziert mache mit vielen Piktogrammen, die sich zwangsläufig damit auseinandersetzen müssen. Das ist vielleicht noch die Sache. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es anders verankert ist. Wir haben alle mal mitgekriegt, dass wir später Kinder haben, zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt die aufklären müssen. Wir kennen das als dieses unangenehme Eltern-Kind-Gespräch, was irgendwann auf uns zukommt. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass sie irgendwie in unserem Alltag das nachher so verwurzelt ist, dass wir automatisch wissen, wenn wir später mal Kinder haben, dann müssen wir ihnen erklären, wie man mit Medien umgeht. Und zwar nicht, wir müssen ihnen alle Medien verbieten, sondern wir müssen ihnen erklären, wie man damit umgeht.
Um deine sehr interessanten Ausführungen kurz zusammenzufassen, man muss es nicht lieben, aber man muss sich damit beschäftigen, um sich ein Urteil erlauben zu dürfen. Blumen auf Fritz, Chaos Radio Teil 125. Wir sind wirklich jetzt eine ganze Weile auf Computerspielen rumgeritten. Es geht eigentlich um den Jugendschutz in Deutschland. Wir waren bei der praktischen Umsetzung. Wie funktioniert es, was habt ihr schon erlebt? Wir haben ganz viele Anrufer gehabt, die gesagt haben, ich bin 12, kann problemlos Dinge, die es ab 18 freigegeben sind, kaufen. Ich kann mir bei Online-Händlern Dinge kaufen, die ab 16 sind. Da gibt es nicht mal eine Frage, ob ich schon 16 wäre. Und in dem Zusammenhang natürlich dann die Geschichte der geforderten noch schärferen Verbote von solchen jugendgefährdenden Gewaltspielen und Gewaltdarstellungen, ob das überhaupt was bringt, wenn sie im Endeffekt in einer praktischen Umsetzung nicht funktionieren. Und wenn sich Eltern und Lehrer und große Geschwister, Onkel, Tanten, wer auch immer, Verkäufer, Videotheksbesitzer, Postboten nicht die Mühe machen, mal drauf zu gucken, was sie da eigentlich an wen ausliefern. Darüber diskutieren wir mit euch. 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste am Telefon ist Sven aus Lichtenberg. Hallo Sven, grüß dich.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Guten Abend, musste ich ein bisschen warten, aber hier brennt heute echt der Baum.
Ich bin ja überhaupt erst mal froh, dass ich überhaupt durchgekommen bin.
Alles klar.
Das ist ja schon seit zwei Wochen das erste Mal, dass ich überhaupt durchgekommen bin.
Mensch, Sven, komm rein, ich freu mich, dass du da bist.
Ich hab sonst wie mal Batterien gewechselt. Also erst mal Punkt Nummer eins. Ich spiel dieses Spiel schon seitdem es draußen ist.
Welches Spiel?
Counter-Strike. Nicht nur solche Spiele. Also ich bin bei sowas sehr bewandert mit solchen Spielen. Nun muss man aber abwägen, kann der Mensch unterscheiden, ist das real oder ist das nicht real? Wenn die Eltern es versäumen, einem Kind beizubringen, das was im Fernsehen läuft, das was auf dem Rechner läuft, ist nicht real, bringt es auch nichts, wenn man das verbietet. Denn es heißt ja nicht umsonst Wide Wide Web. Man kann alles kriegen im Internet. Und wenn sie es verbieten, dann gibt es immer in Amerika die amerikanische Web, dann wird das eben gedownloadet. Das ist doch scheißegal, das interessiert kein Mensch. Es wird auch nicht kontrolliert. Es ist so wie man es sagt. Wide Wide Web, man kriegt alles.
Okay, wie sollte man damit umgehen?
Wie sollte man damit umgehen? Ich sage mal ganz ehrlich, es hört sich jetzt hart an, aber vielleicht wäre es die einfache Variante. Man sollte Kindern, die vielleicht eventuell noch sehr jugendlich erscheinen, vielleicht aber geistig noch nicht so weit sind, eventuell komplett das Computerspielen verbieten. Damit umgeht man das Problem der Kontrolle.
Hey Sven, Entschuldigung, Hand aufs Herz. Wenn du jetzt Leuten sagst, ihr dürft nicht Super Mario spielen, die lachen sich doch kaputt. Und im Zweifelsfall gehen sie zum Kumpel oder zum Nachbarn nebenan und zocken da. Das ist nicht der Weg.
Ich finde das eine Dreißigkeit zu sagen, wir verbieten das Spiel komplett. Damit nimmt man meine Wenigkeit, ich bin 23, die Möglichkeit. Ich bin volljährig, ich hab das Recht, mir so ein Spiel zu kaufen. Ich habe die geistige Weite, um zu sagen, ich unterscheide das. Ich kann das spielen. Aber man entzieht mir ja die Möglichkeit, das Spiel spielen zu können, weil man es einfach komplett verbietet. Man beschneidet mich in meiner Freiheit.
Damit sind wir wieder beim Thema Jugendschutz und genau da, wo wir eigentlich hinwollten. Besonders bestimmte Spiele sind ab 18 freigegeben und nicht für Leute zugänglich zu machen, die unter 18 Jahre alt sind. Sie kriegen sie trotzdem, du hast eben gesagt, im Netz.
Richtig, da müsste man irgendwie mehr Kontrolle. Aber das kann man eben nicht. Ich hab da mal einen Bericht gelesen, das ist schon ein Weilchen her, dass ich glaube, das Internet mal aufgebaut worden ist, um bestimmte Datenaustausch zu produzieren von bestimmten Firmen. Und das Ganze hier außer Kontrolle geraten ist. Man hätte, so wie die Amis das jetzt eigentlich wollten...
Das klingt ein bisschen nach einer Verschwörungstheorie. Warte mal, ich frag mal kurz beim Chaos Computer Club nach, ob das bis hierhin sachlich richtig ist. Internet ist aufgebaut worden zum Datenaustauschen, geriet irgendwann außer Kontrolle.
Na ja, außer Kontrolle ist es nicht wirklich. Ich meine, die Firmen haben es jetzt unter Kontrolle. Also ich meine, es gibt ja auch immer in Deutschland, es gab ja auch nach Emstetten auch Widerrufe, das Internet, klar, es wurde schon quasi als Quelle ausgemacht für diese Spiele, wo diese Spiele herkommen. Und deswegen hat man gesagt, okay, den machen wir halt, zensieren wir, filtern wir halt das Internet, kein Problem, zack, da ein paar Filter bei den Service-Providern, an den Knotenpunkten und dann ziehen wir den ganzen Kram aus dem Netz raus. Ist natürlich in der Praxis nicht ganz so einfach, aber das wäre natürlich die Extremvariante, das wäre dann das Modell China, was wir denn hätten. Das wäre halt einfach, bestimmte Sachen versuchen, aus dem Internet zu sperren und es dann auch konsequent durchsetzen. Also entweder macht man halt Zensur ganz oder gar nicht.
Ja, deswegen sag ich ja, es wäre der einfache Weg. Wenn sie schon sagen, wir verbieten die Spiele, dann müssten sie auch das durchführen.
Na Moment Sven, ich glaube, gleich ist es anders dran, aber ich glaube du machst das dir an dem Moment aus deiner egoistischen Perspektive als Soccer ein bisschen einfach, wenn du sagst, ich trau mir dazu, alle anderen dürfen nicht. Ich glaube, das führt in eine Sackgasse.
Genau auf den Schuh wollte ich auch gerade. Auf der einen Seite beschwerst du dich so ein bisschen darüber, dass du vielleicht in deinen persönlichen Rechten beschnitten wirst, wenn du bestimmte Spiele oder Filme nicht zugänglich hast. Und gleichzeitig bist du aber der Meinung, dass andere, die eventuell vielleicht nicht deine geistige Reife haben, das komplett verbieten. Zu verbieten, also ist dann nicht vielleicht eher Jugendmedienschutz, wie er irgendwie versucht wird zu praktizieren, ein viel besserer Ansatz, dass man irgendwie sagt, ab einem bestimmten Alter hat man irgendwie eine bestimmte geistige Reife, um bestimmte Sachen zu verstehen oder nicht. Ob das natürlich bestimmt bei verschiedenen Leuten differenziert nochmal zu sehen ist, ist eine andere Sache.
Wär es auch derjenige, der sozusagen einschätzt, der 12-jährige kann Spiele ab 16 zocken oder einen Film ab 16 sehen und der andere nicht? Das ist eine lange Diskussion, Sven. Wir werden die mit vielen Leuten heute noch weiterführen, aber deine Anregungen werden auf jeden Fall in die Diskussion mit eingehen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Ich sag mal so, man kann nicht beurteilen, der Mensch ist geistig nicht auf der Höhe. Das ist richtig. Ich muss dazu mal sagen, ich hab mir das ja auch mit diesem Armoklauf angeguckt und ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin auch Opfer eines Mobbings in der Schule. Es ist ja nicht so, dass das nur das Spiel ist. Das ist absolut falsch, war ich ganz ehrlich. Es hat mit dem Umfeld der Person zu tun. Wie wird eine Person behandelt, ja? Und das ist eben der Ausschlag. Nicht das Spiel selber, nicht der Film selber. Weil ich denke mal, dass man sich das nicht als Vor- als wie sagt man, sagen kann, das ist jetzt da passiert, so handle ich. Das funktioniert nicht. So doof kann kein Mensch sein. Sondern es hat immer einen anderen Ausschlag. Und deswegen, die Biokraten da oben machen es sich sehr einfach. Sie schlagen sozusagen, denken, sie schlagen zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe.
Und auf der anderen Seite müssten sich eigentlich die Leute, die direkt davon betroffen sind, nämlich deine Eltern, deine Lehrer, deine Freunde, wer auch immer. Die Lehrer vor allen Dingen. Der Lehrer würde jetzt wieder sagen, Alter, ich hab Unterrichtsvorbereitungen, kann mich auch nicht noch darum kümmern, was der Sven im Privaten macht. Da müssen sich deine Eltern drum kümmern, da müssen sich deine Kumpels auch ein bisschen drum kümmern und sagen, Alter, was ist mit dir los?
Das meine ich ja nicht.
Da sollte sich schon jeder an die eigene Nase fassen.
Das meine ich ja nicht. Aber wenn man zum Beispiel als Schüler kommt und sagt, Herr Direktor, ich habe Probleme, ich werde je mobbt, ich werde fertiggemacht. Irgendwann bist du geistig so abwesen und sagst, es ist dir scheißegal. Und da hilft dir keiner, weil sie versuchen es alle unter einem Teppich zu kehren.
Genau, da sind wir an dem Punkt und da sollten sich alle, die es versuchen, unter einen Teppich zu kehren, jeder Einzelne bitte an seine Nase fassen und sich überlegen, welche Verantwortung er da gegenüber seinen Kumpels hat. Sven, pass auf, wir haben einen Haufen Anrufer. Deswegen will ich dich jetzt aus der Leitung kicken.
Ich will auch nicht weiter. Ich bedanke mich, wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend.
Vom selben Haus rein. 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über die Wirksamkeit von Jugendschutz in Deutschland, wie er momentan funktioniert, wie ihr ihn erlebt habt und was man machen kann, damit er wirksam oder praktikabel ist, vielleicht eher ein schöneres Wort als wirksam, umzusetzen ist, damit das, was beabsichtigt wird, nämlich Jugendliche bei der Mediennutzung, ein bisschen vor Dingen zu schützen, die sie nicht unbedingt sehen sollten, damit es auch funktioniert.
Und vor allem würde uns interessieren, wenn ihr Eltern seid, ruft auch mal an. Uns interessiert mal, wie würdet ihr mit euren Kindern umgehen, wie geht ihr mit euren Kindern damit um? Gerade wenn ihr also Eltern seid, ruft auch jetzt mal bitte an.
Aber erstmal sagt der Elektriker hier die Zeit.
Fritz.
Chaos Radio Teil 125 mit Frank Anett und Thorsten vom Chaos Computer Club. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Herzlich willkommen. Die Leitungen sind immer noch extrem voll. Ihr könnt auch gerne unter fritz.de im Fritzboard oder unter chaosradio.ccc.de euch in den Chaos Radio Chat einloggen und da auch mitdiskutieren. Eure Meinungen sind alle willkommen. Wir reden über den Jugendschutz in Deutschland. Der nächste am Telefon ist Christian aus Schwerin namens Christian. Oder jetzt quasi guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen.
Mein Computer sagt mir, du bist Spielehändler.
Ich habe einen Second Hand Shop und mache ungefähr 50 Prozent meines Umsatzes mit Spielen aus Playstation 2, Xbox und Gamecube und so weiter.
Na dann plauder doch mal aus dem Nähkästchen.
Ja, also bei mir ist es so, wenn junge Leute kommen, 16, 17, wollen ein 18er-Spieler haben, bei mir kriegen sie sie nicht, sondern nur mit den Eltern, also die müssen dann schon mitkommen. Die meisten kommen auch mit und kaufen die Sachen auch. Nur ist es so, muss ich sagen, so 70 Prozent, da klappt das auch. Bei den restlichen 30 Prozent, die sagen dann auch mal nein. Also das ist schon ziemlich interessant.
Also die Eltern kommen, sehen das Spiel und sagen, kaufe ich nicht?
Genau, ja. Also das sind ungefähr 30 Prozent aus meinen eigenen Erfahrungen hier.
Zu den anderen 70 Prozent sagst du denn irgendwas?
Ja, natürlich, ja, mache ich auch. Also ich mache die Eltern auf jeden Fall darauf aufmerksam. Also das ist da und damit. Aber wie gesagt, man kann diese Spiele ja auch nicht verallgemeinern, das ist ja immer das Problem. Man kann ja nicht, ja, wie soll ich sagen, das eine Spiel ist Sohn, das andere Spiel ist Sohn, das haben wir ja heute, ich habe ja zugehört, die Probleme schon, dass diese Bewertungen sehr allgemein sind. Also ich finde, ich bin auch Vater einer siebenjährigen Tochter und die lasse ich nur ordentlich alles machen, an Spielen oder im Internet oder sonst irgendwo. Also da achte ich schon drauf. Und ich denke, wir können in Deutschland so viel verbieten wie wir wollen, es wird immer wieder einen Weg geben. So wie zum Beispiel jetzt, weiß ich, vor ein, zwei Jahren wurde verboten, dass irgendwelche Kopierschutzprogramme auf Deutsch verkauft werden. Ich meine, die kann man sich auch stammend aus dem Internet runterladen und dann trotzdem irgendwelche Kopien knacken, also Originale knacken damit.
Ich glaube, bei diesem Jugendschutz oder jungen Medienschutz geht es auch nicht so sehr um Verallgemeinerung. Das ist schon klar, dass es verschiedene Sorten und Arten von Computerspielen, von Filmen, etc. gibt. Es geht erstmal darum, dass in diesen verschiedenen Inhalte sind, die ein Gremium für kritisch empfunden hat und deswegen gesagt hat, irgendwie Stempel drauf ab 18.
Na klar, aber wie gesagt, das ist halt sehr verallgemeinert. Man kann ja...
Kann ich ganz kurz? Deswegen ist es ja eigentlich deine Aufgabe als Elternteil, okay, sich dieses Spiel zu nehmen, auf die Rückseite das OSK-Siegel, oh, ab 18, naja, ich kann ja mal angucken, was da so drin ist und vielleicht eventuell mir das Film oder das Computerspiel mal durchspielen. Und dann kann ich ja als Elternteil, das ist dein gutes Recht und auch deine Pflicht letztendlich, sagen, will ich das meiner Tochter spielen lassen oder will ich das nicht? Also weil nur du als Elternteil hast ja auch die Ansicht darüber, wie weit oder wie reif dein Kind ist und mit welchen Sachen es schon umgehen kann und wie weit es vielleicht in seiner Medienkompetenz oder überhaupt ist.
Dieser Meinung bin ich ja absolut auch. Also es ist so, ich meine, es heißt USK. Das heißt, das ist eine Empfehlung letztendlich. Für mich als Händler ist es natürlich bindend, aber eigentlich ist es eine Empfehlung. Und ich hab mir jetzt gerade drei Spiele rausgesucht, das ist einmal Ab durch die Hecke, das ist King Kong und das ist Call of Duty. Und da steht eine Pegi-Info drauf. Bei Ab durch die Hecke ist es 3+, Pegi, USK, 6. Dann kommt, das sind gute Beispiele, Peter Jacksons King Kong, das Spiel zum Film, 12 von Pegi und 12 von USK. Und dann kommt Call of Duty, Fein ist Auer. Ballerspiel, 16 Pegi und 18, also rote Keinzeichnung, USK.
Torsten vom CTC kann die Unterschiede zwischen Pegi und USK sich noch mal kurz erläutern.
Was er anspricht, ist genau der Punkt. Da ist eben auch das Problem von Pegi. Pegi ist auf allen Packungen drauf gedruckt, weil es europaweit in vielen Ländern gültig ist, aber in Deutschland eben nicht. In Deutschland haben wir die USK und die Pegi interessiert uns eigentlich gar nicht. Es ist ein nettes System aus unserer Sicht, aber wir haben die USK. Als Elternteil hast du natürlich wahrscheinlich überhaupt keinen Plan und hast eben beide Siegel drauf. Pegi ist zum Teil sogar noch größer als das USK-Siegel, das ja vergleichsweise klein ist. Das heißt, wir haben da auf jeden Fall Verwirrung. Also die Einstufung 3 Plus haben wir einfach nicht. Also in allen Medien haben wir einfach erst mal ohne Altersfreigabe oder dann 6, 3 Plus ist vollkommen unbekannt. Und natürlich funktionieren diese Systeme anders. Also beim Pegi-System wurde dieses Spiel einfach von keinem Gremium begutachtet. Da hat einfach der Produzent das Spiel nach einem Raster am Internet selber klassifiziert. Spiele, die dann eine Bewertung auf 18 kriegen würden, werden dann noch mal näher angesehen. Ansonsten, ab 16 gehen die halt dann so raus, dass es Pegi-Siegel und gut ist. Also jetzt ganz, ganz grob gesagt. Deswegen trägt Pegi da auch durchaus Verwirrung bei, da gebe ich dir recht.
Ich meine eher, dass man vielleicht auch daran sieht, wie unterschiedlich dann auch bewertet wird, welche Gruppe nun gerade da ist, welches Wetter gerade ist oder welche Würfel gerade gefallen sind.
Das hast du ja auch schon in Deutschland. Du hast bei allen Selbstkontrollen wirklich auch die Möglichkeit, Berufen einzulegen als Produzent. Dann tritt ein neues Gremium zusammen und dieses Gremium kann natürlich zu einer anderen Entscheidung kommen. Aber das ist ja auch eben das Wichtige. Das sind eben Medienprodukte, die man sich wirklich ansehen muss und wo man eben unterschiedlicher Ansicht sein kann. Deswegen auch diese fruchtbare Diskussion. Nochmal bei Peggy, es hat dann keiner gesehen. Also da gibt es halt kein Gremium, da ist dann auch das Wetter egal. Aber in der USK natürlich, du kannst Berufe einlegen, neues Gremium, neue Bewertung. Also das ist auf jeden Fall möglich.
Ja, ich meine aber wie gesagt insgesamt ist das zwar ein guter Hinweis und so weiter, aber letztendlich sollten wir auch ein bisschen mehr Eigenverantwortung in Deutschland übernehmen, statt alles zu verbieten. Ich meine, wir haben nur wirklich genug Verbote in Deutschland.
Und um uns im Zweifelsfall einfach darauf zurückziehen zu können und zu sagen, wir haben ein Verbot und darum muss ich jemand kümmern und die Verantwortung ist nicht meine. Das ist nämlich der einfachste und der Holzweg.
Und was verboten ist, gibt es nicht.
Je mehr Verbote man natürlich erteilt, desto mehr muss auch kontrolliert werden.
Richtig.
Und das passiert ja gar nicht. Also wie gesagt, ich sehe es selbst als Händler. Also bei mir war noch nie jemand, der sich mal irgendwie beschwert hat oder so. Hier du hast ein Spiel so und so verkauft. Ich kann natürlich auch keine 12-Jährigen mit 13-Jährigen unterscheiden oder so, weil die haben keinen Ausweis und gar nichts.
Weißt du denn als Händler, welche Strafe dir droht?
Ja, natürlich ja. Das sind schon ein paar Tausend Euro. Nee, da hab ich auch gar keinen Bock drauf. Also ich bestecke dann auch nur mal auf einen 20er, auf einen 30er. Viele kommen auch nicht wieder, weil die Eltern das halt nicht erlaubt haben. Manche haben auch einfach gar keine Lust mitzukommen. Man merkt das auch.
Oder vielleicht nicht mal lustig, da um zu kümmern, was da eigentlich gerade im Laufe der Zeit geht.
Und ich würde es selbst auch nicht mit meinem Gewissen vereinbaren können. Also das muss nicht sein.
Christian, vielen Dank für diese Einblicke aus der Spielebranche. Und schönen Abend nach Schwerin. Der nächste am Telefon ist nämlich Philipp aus Dresden, der nochmal was sagen will zu dieser Amazon-Problematik, die wir vorhin schon hatten, dass man als unter 16-Jähriger ein Girokonto hat und sich dann bei Amazon einfach einen Account haben kann und sich dann die Sachen bestellen kann, die eigentlich erst ab 16 freigegeben sind. Namen Philipp. Hallo. Hab ich das richtig zusammengefasst?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Alles klar.
Es ging eigentlich darum, also ja, grob so mit Amazon hat es zu tun. Und zwar, das ist ja auch bei den ganzen Computerspiele-Zeitschriften, also die ist nie bei, was, PC-Professional oder sowas, sondern bei GameStar.
Wie sie alle heißen?
PC, Games, GameStar und sowas. Die sind ja auch alle ab 16.
Die Zeitschriften meinst du jetzt?
Die Zeitschriften sind ab 16. Also die mit DVDs, wo die Demos dabei sind. Und die Abo-Bestellungen im Internet läuft so ab, sag ich mal, denke ich mal eher ähnlich wie Amazon, dass man dort schon ein Geburtsdatum angeben muss, aber es wird halt auch nie getestet.
Oder im Zweifelsfall bist du einfach im Verteiler drin und die schicken dir die Zeitung raus, ohne dass da irgendjemand sitzt und bei jeder Ausgabe prüft, ob die jetzt sozusagen für denjenigen zugänglich ist. Der Aufwand ist auch gigantisch natürlich.
Aber es ist keine Ausrede. Genau, und den Altersnachweis muss man dort auch erst bringen, wenn man die ab 18. Edition haben möchte. Das heißt, dort muss man dann die Kopie vom Ausweis mit schicken, vorher nie.
Wobei es natürlich im Zeitalter von Photoshop wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr so ein Problem ist.
Das geht ja dort einfach nur noch um die Demos, die halt mitgeliefert werden.
Kommt Frank um die Ecke schon wieder mit einer Hacker-Idee. Ja, das ist ein guter Einwurf auf jeden Fall. Da können sich auch mal die Leute, die diese Computerzeitschriften vertreiben oder herstellen, an die eigene Nase fassen.
Die kriegt man ja dann auch in jedem Zeitungsladen. Und da kontrolliert ja auch quasi keiner.
Im Zweifelsfall ist morgens um 7 am Hauptbahnhof auch mehr Trubel, dass das der Zeitungshändler im Akkord die Zeitung rausgibt und zwischendurch irgendjemand diese Zeitschrift da durchschiebt. Gut, Philipp, hast du vielleicht noch einen Ansatz, wie man das mit dem Jugendschutz drehen kann?
Na, das Jugendschutzproblem war ja noch, sag ich mal, das würde ich jetzt nicht nur so auf das, sag mal, Computerspiele beziehen. Das ist ja eigentlich Medienschutz und das ist ja auch Fernsehen und alles mögliche andere. Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, wenn man, sag ich mal, grob abends die Nachrichten einschaltet, sieht man ja auch, 50 Prozent davon, in Bagdad haben sich 50 Leute abgeknallt und danach kommt Sturp langsam, wo der Superheld durch die Gegend zieht und alle abknallt. Und da würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, dass das für die Jugend besser ist. Auch wenn das dann schon 20 oder 22 Uhr im Fernsehen kommt.
Zack, da kommt sofort eine Wortmeldung von Annett.
Genau, es kam 22 Uhr im Fernsehen und da ist die FSF, die Freiwillige Selbstkontrolle Fernsehen, für zuständig, die dann halt nach den Altersbestimmungen sagt, um welche Uhrzeitsachen laufen können. Und in einem vernünftigen Haushalt, die ihre Kinder altersgerecht vielleicht erziehen, ist ein neunjähriger, zehnjähriger eigentlich um 22 Uhr im Bett.
Ach, um 22 Uhr im Fernsehen auf dem Zimmer.
Genau, das haben sie ja sowieso alle.
Kann man Stecker ziehen.
Und ich sag mal, das haben wir heute, ich möchte jetzt nicht irgendwie verspotten, aber das haben wir heute auch schon 12-jährige nach 22 Uhr angerufen. Und ich sag mal, wenn ich dann zum Beispiel weitergucke, die Metal-Szenen in Herder Ringe 2, der war glaube ich ab 12, die sind auch nicht gerade ohne.
Aber es geht ja, also ich denke, das ist davon aber auch nicht, sagen wir mal, verharmlos, in dem Sinne, als dass es jetzt, es geht ja nicht um Gewaltdarstellung, sondern quasi in welchem Kontext diese Gewalt ist.
Ja, aber ich würde jetzt, ich würde deswegen jetzt nicht unbedingt nur die Computerspieler dort die Schuld draufschieben, weil die Gewalt, dort werden die Jugendlichen eigentlich permanent in allen Medien damit konfrontiert.
Klar, deswegen haben wir auch ein sehr umfangreiches System von Kontrollstellen oder von Bewertungsstellen in Deutschland.
Zu Herr der Ringe wollte ich noch ganz kurz was sagen. Soweit ich weiß, ist das sogar auch ein Kinderbuch oder zumindest ein Kinder- und Jugendbuch. Und dann ist es vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwerer zu sagen, weil da kommt natürlich Gewalt vor. Wir machen es erst ab 16 oder 18, wenn die Vorlage schon ein Kinder- oder Jugendbuch ist.
Wobei die Umsetzung, also auch beim letzten Harry Potter Film, der im Kino war, ich sag mal so als 9- 10-Jähriger, mit den Todessern und dem dunklen Mahlen und den Drachen und so. Ich glaube, da schläft man in der Nacht auch nicht gut.
Aber ich sag mal bei Herr der Ringe, wenn man da mal ein bisschen die Vergangenheit von Peter Jackson kennt, dann müsste man schon mal daran denken, dass da die Szenen auch ein bisschen härter sein können.
Worauf spielst du da an?
Ja, also, nein.
Der ist ja soweit ich weiß auch indiziert.
Ja, der ist indiziert. Aber indiziert ist ja nicht verboten.
Richtig, aber wie hast du ihn bekommen? In welchem Rahmen hast du den gesehen?
In welchem Rahmen? Tauschbörsen. Also ich sag mal, sowas kriegt man dann schon relativ schwer noch unter der Ladentheke. Also runtergeladen und dann geguckt halt.
Und konntest du die Indizierung nachvollziehen oder hättest du ihn auch freigegeben für Kinder und Jugendliche?
Ich sag mal, er ist schon hart. Ab 18 ist er in Ordnung, weil die Gewaltdarstellung dazu nie ist natürlich übertrieben. Also auch eigentlich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar. Und wer das irgendwie auf eine reale Ebene bezieht, ist für mich ein Spinner. Aber es ist halt auch nichts Leichtes. Also als 16 würde ich das auch noch nicht sehen lassen.
Ich glaube, es geht auch nicht immer darum, dass man irgendwelche Fiktionen auf die reale Ebene zieht, sondern es geht, wenn Sachen zum Beispiel indiziert werden, ganz klar darum, dass bestimmte Sachen verherrlicht werden, zum Beispiel Gewalt.
Es gibt, wenn ich da kurz einwirken darf, es gibt natürlich, besonders bei so Geschichten wie diese Amokläufen, immer auch die Kritik, a, sie sind Computerspiele, b, es ist die Musik. Marilyn Manson hatten sie an der Backe, dann hatten sie Slipknot an der Backe, dann hatten sie auch Cannibal Cows immer mal wieder an der Backe. Also alles Bands, die durchaus im weitesten Sinne irgendwie auch ruppig reagieren und die Musiker sagen dann, hey, was wir hier machen, ist nichts anderes als eine Geschichte erzählen, ein Buch schreiben, das ist bei einem Film ganz genauso, das ist bei einem Buch ganz genauso, aber die Musiker kriegen sie an der Backe, weil die eben auch noch quasi die Kinder aufstacheln und bei Filmen oder bei Büchern oder bei Videos macht sich da überhaupt keiner mit einer Birne. Also da wird mit zwei allerlei Maß gemessen.
Wobei das auch immer eine Entwicklung ist. Also du hast halt immer das aktuellste Medium, ist dann immer Schuld. Also natürlich zu Zeiten, wo es noch keine Videospiele gab, waren es halt schon die Kinofilme und sobald dann Videospiele auftauen. Du wirst merken, in ein paar Jahren sind Filme einfach so etabliert wie Bücher und überhaupt nicht mehr eine Diskussion, weil halt immer neuere Medien im Vordergrund stehen.
Um was denkst du, was es für Diskussionen gab, als die ersten Bücher rauskamen und irgendwie bestimmte Mädchenromane, dass Mädchen zu Leseratten werden und etc.
Als es noch keine Filme groß und keine Bücher gab, gab es einen Typen namens Elvis Presley, der quasi auch der Leibhaftige persönlich war.
Aber da gab es auch schon Bücher, als sollte es noch nicht.
Einen dritten Punkt hab ich eigentlich noch. Und zwar, dass es ja eigentlich auch so ist, dass, sag mal, für die Jugendlichen, wenn sie sich nicht selbst organisieren, eigentlich nichts mehr gibt in der Freizeit. Wenn ich das bei uns sehe, in Dresden werden Jugendclubs an Augenmaß geschlossen. Also wo sich jetzt mal, sag ich, auch Leute, die jetzt vielleicht einen großen Freundeskreis haben oder eher ausgegrenzt sind, auch mal hingehen können, gibt es eigentlich kaum noch jetzt öffentliche Jugendclubs. Die werden halt immer weiter geschlossen. In der Schule muss ein Lehrer vor 30 Schülern unterrichten. Da kann man dann auch wirklich nie von einem Lehrer erwarten, dass der dort das Problem kennt, rausfindet.
Kann man auch nicht, aber man kann es durchaus von den Schülern untereinander, von der Clique, von den Kumpels, von sonstigen erwarten, dass der eine auf den anderen ein bisschen aufpasst.
Ich möchte aber gar nicht raus. Das ist ja auch klar. Aber es wird ja auch immer gesagt, die Lehrer müssten dort mehr aufpassen.
Das ist eine ganz einfache Schuld hin und her Schiebung von Leuten, die zu feige oder zu faul sind, selbst die Verantwortung zu nehmen.
Ich denke aber auch, wir können von unseren Politikern mal ein bisschen fördern, dass für Bildung ein bisschen mehr investiert wird und nicht ein Lehrer vor einer Klasse mit 30 Kindern sitzen muss und nicht der 10. Club schon wieder geschlossen wird und die Kinder sich an der Tankstelle treffen müssen.
Genau, das finde ich eigentlich noch viel schlimmer als immer dieses Schuld hin und her schieben. Das sind wirklich diese Probleme, die eigentlich, dass die Jugend nichts anderes mehr zu tun hat eigentlich, wenn sie nicht selber irgendwas auf die Beine stellt.
Genau, genau.
Dass sie dann eigentlich nur vom Rechner sitzen kann oder sich betrinken kann oder...
Oder vielleicht klöppeln lernt oder sonstige vergesste Handwerke. Philipp, danke für den Anruf. Jetzt habe ich ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil wir haben zwei Leute, die dir extrem lange warten. Zum einen Janos Brehm und zum anderen Axel aus Hohenschönhausen. Der nächste ist Axel.
Bist du noch da?
Ja, bin ich.
Guten Abend.
Du hast jetzt fast eine Stunde gewartet. Entschuldige bitte und danke für die Geduld.
Keine Frage.
Wir waren bei Jugendschutz. Wie funktioniert er? Was sollte besser gemacht werden und was sollte für wen zugänglich gemacht werden?
Da ich relativ zeitig angerufen hatte, hatte ich noch einen ganz anderen Einspumpunkt, nämlich tatsächlich den Erfinder des Betriebssystems, also Linus.
Linus, der als Erster angerufen hat, der Zwölfjährige, der erzählt hat, dass er spürt ab 18 spürt.
Dass er mit einer Brusthaut für die Stolle durch die Gegend schießt. Und an der Stelle habe ich ein richtiges Problem. Nicht weil er 12 Jahre alt ist, sondern weil ich überhaupt damit ein Problem habe. Vielleicht habe ich einfach zu Zeiten, da ich noch mit Waffen zu tun hatte, weil ich halt bei der Armee war, ein bisschen zu viel gesehen habe, was damit schiefgehen kann. Und ich habe ein grundsätzliches Problem, Waffen auf andere Leute zu richten. Bei aller Liebe, das ist kein Spielzeug. Spätestens wenn es in der Realität passiert. Und an der Stelle haben wir in Deutschland ein bisschen ein sehr liberales Waffengesetz, also was mir wesentlich zu liberal ist. Weil wenn ich irgendwelche Waffen, sei es Gasbrugwaffen oder ähnliche verkaufe, die schon auf zwei Meter Entfernung nicht mehr von Arealen zu unterscheiden sind, dann kann ich auch eine gewisse Bedrohungslage verstehen, die aus anderer Richtung passiert. An der Stelle, denke ich, muss man grundsätzlich erst mal irgendetwas ändern.
Das heißt, deine Kinder dürften weder Gotcha noch auch Ego-Shootern am Rechner spielen?
Gotcha definitiv nein. Keine Frage. Ego-Shootern ist so eine Sache auch. Ich habe ein Problem, tatsächlich auch in einer Simulation Waffen auf Leute zu richten. Und wenn mir da jemand sagt, ich muss doch da aber taktische Überlegungen hin und her, dann ist das eigentlich nur eine Verbesserung der Simulation. Das ist nicht was einfach Blödes wie ein Schiess, wie ein Tontaubenschießen oder was weiß ich, irgendwie auf Bälle, mit Bällen auf Pyramiden werfen. Ist so doch irgendwie nur eine Verbesserung und eine Erhöhung des Anreiz. Nun kann man natürlich die Sache weit ausmalen und sagen, okay, dann darfst du auch keine Schachsimulation zu lassen. Spätestens mit dem Felsensieh-Schach, wo die Leute sich gar heftig um die Ecke bringen oder gar beim Harry Potter Teil 1, wo die Figuren sich auch mehr gegenseitig erst mal. Ist das schon natürlich ein Problem.
Aber Axel, du darfst nicht, du darfst nicht, du darfst nicht, das haben wir ja heute schon geklärt, führt ja eigentlich nur dazu, dass man sagt, jetzt will ich erst recht. Also muss es anders funktionieren.
Das funktioniert auch nicht. Einen kleinen Gedankensprung, der aber im Endeffekt wieder zum Ziel führt. Ich habe vor einiger Zeit einen interessanten Vortrag des Leiters des Kriminalinstitutes in Hannover, KFN, Pfeiffer, Christian, Christoph Pfeiffer gehört, der eine ganz interessante Geschichte erzählte. Der hat eine Umfrage oder eine Studie gemacht, in dem er die Leute gefragt hat, was sie glauben, woran die meisten Leute heutzutage sterben. Bei den Zwölf- bis Sechzehnjährigen kam heraus, dass sie glauben, dass 30% der Leute an Gewaltverbrechen sterben. Und an der Stelle glaube ich, haben wir richtig wesentlich etwas zu tun mit dem Medienkonsum. Und zwar nicht nur mit Computerspielen, die immer als das Böse hingestellt werden, die ich sicherlich auch nicht für sonderlich schön finde, insbesondere dann, wenn es darum geht, Leute möglichst qualvoll vom Leben zum Tode zu befördern, wie es bei irgendwelchen Mafiaspielen vielleicht sein mag. Vielleicht noch mehr Punkte, die qualvoller ich den Herrn umbringe. Da würden wir also sozusagen eine Foltersimulation erfinden. Da ist dann schon ein Problem. Aber das ist natürlich wirklich nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Das Hauptproblem ist ja ein Großteil privater Medien, die ja nicht das Interesse haben, Informationen zu verbreiten, sondern die das Interesse haben, Geld zu verdienen. Das heißt, das verkauft sich eigentlich wesentlich besser, wenn ich irgendeine Nachricht verbreite, aber sage, und im Anschluss einen Bericht über den kleinen Sohn, der seinen Vater erschießt. Und wenn das im Nachhinein dann auch bloß herauskommt, dass das irgendwo weit weg ist und gar nicht mal in Deutschland, so muss ich doch dann an der Stelle tatsächlich sagen, das große Problem ist ein privates Nachrichtenmedium. Und wenn man sich in Nachrichten genau auf dieses verlässt, ist man rettungslos verloren. Erschreckt war ich vom Herrn Pfeiffer dann, dass es eigentlich eine Bankrotterklärung war von ihm, dass er sagt, wir können uns nicht dagegen wehren. Wir können den Privatsendern es nicht verbieten. Privatmedien, Fernsehen, Radio, können es nicht verbieten. Wir können bloß irgendwelche Richtlinien schaffen, dass manche Sachen nicht zu jedem Zeitpunkt zu sehen sind. Aber im Endeffekt können wir überhaupt nichts dagegen machen, wie und was sie mit Gewalt in der Öffentlichkeit tun.
Axel, Luft holen, hier kommen sofort zwei Wortmeldungen.
Ich wollte auch nochmal ganz klar sagen, wir wollen auch nicht verbieten. Ich will auf jeden Fall nicht verbieten. Das würde für mich in die Richtung Zensur gehen. Und Zensur ist was, was ich für völlig negativ halte. Jugendmedienschutz beschäftigt sich mit Vorschlägen, mit Bestimmungen, aber nicht mit dem Verbot bestimmter Inhalte, zum Beispiel in Nachrichtensendungen. Da geht es dann darum, um welche Uhrzeiten die gesendet werden. Und ich ganz kurz als Erwachsener möchte mir auch gerne das Recht herausnehmen, selber zu entscheiden, weil ich mir zum Beispiel sage, dass ich medienkompetent bin, welche Nachrichten ich mir angucke und dann selbst zu unterscheiden, was halte ich für wahre Münze und was nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob man manchmal nicht mal überlegen sollte, für sich privat, muss ich das wirklich alles haben, oder ist es vielleicht eine bessere Idee für die Allgemeinheit, wenn die Allgemeinheit darauf verzichtet?
Das ist quasi das, was Annett gerade sagte. Ich kann für mich selber entscheiden, welche Nachrichten ich nicht angucke, aber einen großen Sack zu nehmen, alle reinzustecken und drauf zu hauen, ist wahrscheinlich...
Ich habe immer ein kleines Problem, ein wirklich kleines Problem, nicht groß, ein kleines Problem damit, wenn alle Leute sagen, ja, ich fühle mich dann in meiner persönlichen Freiheit eingegrenzt. Persönliche Freiheit um jeden Preis habe ich dann ein Problem damit. Und wenn es um den Preis ist, dass ich dann tatsächlich zwar für mich alles machen und tun kann, aber der hat übertrieben gesagt, der Rest der Welt um mich im Sumpf versinkt, dann ist da mit der persönlichen Freiheit eine gewisse Grenze zu ziehen. Darüber kann man jetzt, glaube ich, lange streiten, führt uns jetzt vom Thema weg.
Richtig.
Da ist wirklich nur die Frage, vielleicht sollte man manchmal auch persönliche Interessen ein bisschen hinten anstellen.
Du bist ein erwachsener Mann, du kannst selber entscheiden, was du dir antun willst und was nicht. Und der Spruch heißt nicht umsonst, sich über irgendwas ärgern.
Aber das Thema ist natürlich schon auch Medienkompetenz. Insofern kommen wir da nicht ganz vom Thema ab. Weil letztendlich geht es ja darum, auf was für ein innenpolitisches Klima herrscht. Und wenn innenpolitisches Klima herrscht von Bedrohung, Angst und wir werden alle Gewaltopfer, dann hat es natürlich auch Auswirkungen auf die Politik, vor allem auf die Innenpolitik, auf die Gesetze, die gemacht werden, auf irgendwelche Überwachungsmechanismen, die geschaffen werden. Und da setzt natürlich sehr wohl wieder die Medienkompetenz ein.
Und an der Stelle ist natürlich dann gleich wieder die bitterböse Frage, die sofort drei Meilen nach Verschwörungstheorie riecht. Hat man nicht ein gewisses Interesse daran. Um eben seine Gesetze durchsetzen zu können?
Also ich war auch gerade ein bisschen, als ich hörte, wer das gesagt hatte, muss ich halt auch sagen, okay, naja, klar, aus der Ecke hätte ich sowas natürlich auch erwartet.
Kann vielleicht noch jemand was zu Herrn Christian Pfeiffer erzählen?
Ich kann nicht viel zu ihm sagen. Ich habe also jetzt alles, was er veröffentlicht, nicht gelesen. Es begegnet einem gelegentlich, wenn man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt, beziehungsweise er kann ihm auch relativ schnell begegnen, also gerade nach Emstetten hat er sich auch hervorgetan, indem er die USK abschaffen wollte, weil er meinte, sie funktioniert offenbar nicht. Ich finde Pfeiffer, was ich von ihm kenne, sehr problematisch. Und eben auch das Genannte kann man natürlich ziemlich leicht auseinandernehmen. Dass Kinder und Jugendliche falsche Zahlen wiedergeben oder ein anderes Bild wiedergeben, das ist, glaube ich, fast ein Charakteristiker von Kindheit und Jugendlichkeit, ist für mich überhaupt kein Beleg, er hat eine Art Medienwirkung, deswegen finde ich Pfeiffer den meisten Sachen, die er sagt und macht, recht pfeifelhaft. Aber ich bin trotzdem dankbar für seine Erwähnung und ich bin Axel auch dankbar für die Erwähnung des Privatfernsehens, weil das ist natürlich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Es ist eben kein öffentlich-rechtliches Angebot, was uns diktiert wird, sondern es ist schon auch in gewisser Weise das, was wir sehen wollen. Also dass die Privaten mit diesem Programm, das du jetzt kritisierst, erfolgreich sind, zeigt ja auch, dass da ein gewisser Bedarf sein muss. Sonst würden sie es dann nicht senden. Die Privaten würden nicht senden, was gerne guckt, oder?
Ja, da ist nur die Frage, wer wirklich den Bedarf schafft und wodurch der Bedarf geschaffen wird. Aber ich glaube, das können wir jetzt hier nicht auseinandernehmen.
Wirklich, das ist eine andere Baustelle, das ist ein anderer Topf, den wir hier aufmachen. Das führt absolut zu weit. Wir haben nicht mal mehr eine halbe Stunde. Möchtest du noch was sagen, Frank? Sonst wünsche ich Axel jetzt eine schöne Nacht.
Genau, wünschen wir ihm. Ich wollte mich noch eine kleine Ankündigung machen.
Axel, danke für den Anruf. Ich würde sagen, eine kurze, gewaltverherrlichende Musik, dann deine Ankündigung, dann die Nachrichten. Ja, Chaosradio 125 auf Fritz.
Steht auf Jonas.
Doch Jonas liebt Vanessa.
Vanessa, der Kerb mit Lars zusammen dort, der findet Melanie besser.
Die allerdings steht eher auf Tim.
Jennifer jedoch ist verliebt mit Kevin.
Tobias will Schauborn, Annika und Annika eigentlich auch auf ihn.
Doch Pech, wenn es schon lange der Schwarm ihrer besten Freundin. Hagen erschießt Sebastian. Sven überfährt Hagen.
Christopher erwirkt Sven und wird von Janik erschlagen.
Benjamin macht Lukas aller und wird von Nils erstochen. Alexander killt Thorsten und Felix und wird erschossen.
So viel dazu. Klokator, Alter Mann. Jetzt wollte Frank noch was sagen.
Genau, ich hab nämlich zwei Ankündigungen. Zum einen ist natürlich das Chaos Communication Camp, was im August stattfindet, von 8 bis 12 an dem Wochenende, wo ihr alle ganz herzlich gebeten seid zu kommen. Das ist eine große Hacker Party, wo wir alle unsere Zelte mitbringen, unsere Computer und es gibt Internet, es gibt Vorträge und es wird immer eine ganz großartige Veranstaltung. Das andere ist, wer sich von euch aus dem Raum Berlin für so Mikrocontroller, das sind also kleine programmierbare Chips, Mikrocontroller halt interessiert und damit selber gerne basteln will. Da haben wir jetzt eine Workshopreihe bei uns, die wir anbieten, nämlich die nächsten Donnerstage. Los geht's nächste Woche, also jetzt nicht morgen, sondern in eine Woche, so ungefähr um 20 Uhr bei uns in der Marienstraße 11, wo man lernt, mit den Dingern was zu löten, was zu basteln und die dann auch zu programmieren. Wenn ihr da Interesse habt, kommt einfach hin oder schreibt auch eine Mail an mail.berlin.ccc.de.
Und wenn ihr das nicht macht, kriegt ihr nächstes Weihnachten keine Geschenke.
Sie sind von einem einfachen Schülerkombot zur begehrtesten Indieband des Planeten aufgestiegen. Montag, 9. Juli. Ab 20 Uhr in der Kolumbiale Berlin. Die Arctic Monkeys live. Rodziger Rock'n'Roll. Und das hört man.
2 nach halb 1.
Fritz-Info. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat dem neuen britischen Premierminister Brown zu seinem Amtsantritt gratuliert. In einer Pressemitteilung hieß es, Merkel habe zudem den Wunsch geäußert, die enge und vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit zwischen beiden Regierungen vorzuführen. Der bisherige Schatzkanzler Brown war heute von Königin Elisabeth II mit der Regierungsbildung beauftragt worden. Er will morgen sein Kabinett vorstellen. Sein Vorgänger Blair wurde inzwischen offiziell zum Sonderbeauftragten des Nahostquartetts ernannt. Bahnchef Medorn bleibt bis 2011 im Amt. Der Aufsichtsrat des Unternehmens teilte nach einer Sitzung mit, dass der Vertrag des 64-Jährigen um drei Jahre verlängert werde. Damit kann Medorn die geplante Privatisierung der Bahn weiter vorantreiben. Der Bundestag hat im November grundsätzlich entschieden, das letzte große Staatsunternehmen in Deutschland bis 2009 in Teilen an die Börse zu bringen. Über das erforderliche Gesetz wird aber weiter gestritten. Bei neun Anschlägen Mirags sind mindestens 27 Menschen getötet worden. Eine Angaben von Sicherheitskräften starben bei der Explosion einer Autobombe in einem Schiitenviertel Bagdads am Abend zehn Menschen. Bei der Detonation eines Sprengensatzes auf einem Markt im Norden der Hauptstadt seien fünf Menschen getötet worden. In Bagdad wurden, den Angaben zur Folge, außerdem die Leichen von 21 Ermordeten entdeckt. Die Hintergründe der Tat sind noch unklar. Die Berliner Feuerwehr ist wegen des Sturms heute über 90 Mal ausgerückt. Wie die Polizei mitteilte, stürzen wegen des starken Windes mit Orkanartigen Böen zahlreiche Bäume um und Bauteile wurden abgerissen. In Kreuzberg kippte ein Baum auf einen fahrenden BVG-Bus. Fünf parkende Autos wurden dabei beschädigt. Menschen kamen aber nicht zu Schaden. In der Nacht wird der Wind weniger und der Regen lässt auch langsam nach. Es kühlt ab auf 12 bis 9 Grad und am Tag bleibt es weiterhin wechselhaft bei 17 bis 19 Grad. Der Verkehr Fritz A12 Berliner Ring Richtung Frankfurt-Oder zwischen Mürose und dem Grenzübergang Frankfurt-Oder gibt Stau, die Lkw-Spur ist blockiert. Bitte fahrt vorsichtig in das Stauende ran. Ansonsten sind die Straßen frei und wir wünschen eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5 dann Fritz in Eisenhütten statt.
Heiliger Schroes, ich glaube es war 1980 oder 81, aber nagel mich jetzt darauf nicht wirklich fest. Abwärts der Computer-Stadt im Chaos Radio 125, dem Blue Moon immer am letzten Mittwoch auf Fritz. Wir reden heute über Jugendschutz. Ich mach jetzt mal die Anmoderation eins kurz. Ich glaube, ihr habt mitbekommen, worum es geht. Wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit. Deswegen jetzt ganz schnell eine nach dem anderen mit kurzen Statements. Ich hoffe, es ist für euch okay. Der Erste am Telefon ist Jan aus Bremen. Guten Abend, Jan.
Erwider ich mal. Mir gerade mal aufgefallen ist, allein die Nachrichten hier, die eben eingeblendet wurden, begannen damit, dass es 27 Tote im Irak gab durch einen Terroranschlag.
Ja, sollen wir das nicht melden und sollen stattdessen sagen, dass die Gänseblümchen den Nichts wieder blühen?
Ich meinte nur so. Und dann kam danach noch ein paar Details, wo man irgendwie Leichen gefunden hat und so. Also es scheint sehr vom Medien um abhängig zu sein, ob sich darüber irgendjemand aufregt. Vor jetzt anderthalb Wochen oder so wurde es gerade im Radio ja auch sehr breit getreten, dass man irgendwie 15 fast tote Kinder in einem Weißenhaus festgekettet gefunden hat und so, ja.
Das sind, du, Jan, das sind die Dinge, die auf dieser Welt wirklich passieren.
Genau. Was ist also, und kein, darüber, es wird sich weniger in den Medien jedoch darüber aufgeregt, was tatsächlich passiert, als das, was irgendwie auf dem Bildschirm passiert.
Ich glaube, die Diskussion führt jetzt gerade ein bisschen weit weg. Und nur um das ganz kurz zu erklären, die Medien, also quasi wir in den Nachrichten, sind nicht dazu da, sich darüber aufzuregen, dass so was passiert, sondern sie sind dazu da, darüber zu berichten, dass so was passiert.
Ja, und das ist ja auch sehr erstrebenswert.
Richtig.
Nur darin erfährt man wesentlich brutalere Dinge als das, was auf dem Bildschirm passiert.
Du meinst, was in Computerspielen passiert. Oder in Filmen oder bei Büchern.
Womit es wieder ein Thema wäre. Ich habe früher beides gerne gespielt, sowohl an Real Tournament und was ja an sich völlig hohl ist und auch ziemlich gewalttätig. Kann man anders nicht sagen. Das erste bin ich die Abklatsche, die danach kam. Jedoch als Mehrspielerspiel sehr interessant ist, weil es Teamfähigkeit fördert und voraussetzt. Weil als Einzelgänger man keine Chance hat. Auf gerselben Enden jedoch basiert das, meiner Meinung nach, noch wesentlich besseres Spiel, wenn es auch schlecht vergleichbar ist, Deus Ex. Das ist ebenfalls ein sehr gewalttätiges Spiel. Anders kann man es nicht bezeichnen.
Warte mal, ich breche dich jetzt kurz ab, bevor wir weiter über die Details dieser Spiele reden. Du bist 18 oder 19, rufst aus Bremen jetzt an, und sagst, du hast die Spiele gespielt. Wann hast du damit angefangen? Mit welcher Freigabe waren die damals? Wie bist du da herangekommen?
Also die sind alle zusammen ab 18. In der deutschen Version. Ich hatte die internationale Version von beiden.
Und du hast die aus dem Netz?
Nein. Ich habe die von einem Bekannten, der die international Version damals übers Netz bestellt hat.
Ach so, und der hat sich nicht mal mit dir darüber geredet?
Doch, das hat auch für einige Konflikte gesorgt. Irgendwann hatte ich meine Eltern überzeugt, dass sie mich das haben spielen lassen, nachdem sie sich das angeguckt haben und meine Reaktionen darauf sich angeguckt haben.
Wie hast du das geschafft, sie zu überzeugen?
In dem, dass ich erst mal quasi einen Dickkopf markiert habe und das Spiel hier hat, das haben sie natürlich nicht zugelassen. Sie haben dann gesagt, hier steht 18 drauf, erstmal soll ich mir das angucken. Und dann habe ich ihnen gezeigt, was diese Spiele, ja, was die bewirken auf mich, wie ich sie spiele und was das Ziel dabei ist.
Was bewirken denn diese Computerspiele bei dir?
Ähm, damals durchaus aufputschend und so, ja. Und kurzfristig auch aggressionsfördernd, dann durchaus, ja. Weil sie einfach einen sehr unter Stress setzen, wenn man, und das für sie schwer zu unterscheiden war ursprünglich.
Okay, pass auf um die Frage, weil jetzt ein bisschen die Zeit wegläuft und ehe wir jetzt hier noch Unreal Tournament und Deus Ex weiter... Pass auf, Jan, an dich die Frage, würdest du heute als 19-Jähriger, der du ja quasi freien Zugang zu all diesen Dingern hast, würdest du einem Freund von dir oder deinen Geschwistern, die wesentlich jünger sind als du, solche Dinge an die Hand drücken und sagen kannst du machen?
Ich würde da so mit ihm reden und dann beurteilen, ob ich jetzt verantworten kann diese Informationen, denn das sind ja Informationen, die diese Spiele an sie weiterzugeben.
War ein eindeutiges Ja hin, mit wir müssen drüber reden.
Also nicht pauschal, aber ich kenne durchaus 14-Jährige, denen ich das ohne Bedenken übergeben würde.
Alles klar, danke für deinen Anruf, Jan. So, der nächste, Entschuldigung Leute, aber es läuft echt die Zeit weg und den Rest können wir auf fritz.de noch weiter diskutieren. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen ruppig sein. Nächster am Telefon, wartet schon lange, ist Ben aus Kreuzberg 24. Hallo Ben. Danke für die Geduld.
Ja, kein Problem. Auf jeden Fall.
Wir waren gerade bei Altersfreigaben. Jan hat es ja auch wieder erzählt. Er hat mit unter 18 schon Spiele bekommen, die über 18 sind. Und es war eigentlich ein Leichtes, die Dinger zu zocken. Was hältst du davon?
Na ja, kommt auf meinen Punkt zu. Vor allen Dingen, ich sage es einfach mal so, Altersfreigabe ist witzig, aber irgendwie dann noch sinnlos. Vor allen Dingen in einem Zeitalter, wo es ein Medium gibt, was quasi keine Zensur in der Legen ist. Ich habe es schon in der Berufsschule festgestellt, zum Beispiel ein Gott, wenn da ein neues PC-Spiel draußen ist, dann wird es rumgereicht. Da muss man, wo es die Rohlinge rausgehen, fertig.
Und wie gehen wir damit um?
Ja, ich zock selbst recht gerne, ich finde es gut, mal so gesagt. Am Ende, na gut, den Film tut es weh.
Darum geht es aber gar nicht so. Die Frage ist, würdest du es trotzdem befürworten, dass du dieses Spiel an unter 14-Jährige weitergibst?
Ja, es gibt einige Beispiele, wo ich irgendwie, ich sag mal so, wo ich echt mal eine Zweifel hätte. Also es gibt manche Sachen, die will ich irgendwie Leuten nicht antun. Das macht die Motte, dass sie halt wirklich traumatisiert werden könnten.
Du selber packst es?
Ja, ach, ich zock ja schon seit Jahren. Und ich hab auch schon vom Spielen oder vom Filmen her irgendwie auch schon die schlimmsten Sachen gesehen.
Also du sagst, differenzieren und nicht jedem einfach so pauschal in die Hand drücken. Und eine pauschale Altersfreigabe, wie das ab 16 und sobald man diese 16er Schallmauer durchbrochen hat, kann man dir das alles zutrauen. Ist in dem Fall nicht praktikal.
Ganz ehrlich, die Eltern tragen eine Verantwortung. Die Härte der Medien an sich hat sich verändert, kann man jetzt auch schon am Fernsehprogramm feststellen. Als ich aufgewachsen bin, liegten andere Sachen um 22 Uhr, die jetzt am Nachmittag laufen oder so.
Kannst du dafür ein Beispiel geben?
Ja, okay, das hat vielleicht was mit einem persönlichen Erlebnis zu tun. Ich hatte als 8-Jähriger, 7-Jähriger, wurde mir ziemlich ängstlich, als ich gesehen habe, als bei Grandins eins, die Grandins irgendwie geschmolzen sind.
Oder wenn die Critters sich irgendwie reingebissen haben.
Ja, wie vorletzte Woche oder so, lief es um Sonntag zum Mittagessen. Das ist halt eine komische Sache.
Das ist eben was, woran man gewöhnt ist als Matrix 1. Ganz andere Baustelle als Matrix 1 im Kino war. Da haben wir alle gesessen, waren in Sessel gedrückt. Und dann kommt Matrix 2, 3 und du sagst, ja, ich hab schon gesehen.
Wie gesagt, dieser Song von Knack Carter hat schon ziemlich gut darauf gestimmt. Die meisten Eltern wahrscheinlich darauf reagieren.
Pass auf, Ben, wir schalten mal rüber zu Björn nach Hannover. Weil Björn hat einen Vorschlag, der bei der Dexussion auch immer wieder kommt, zum Thema Mediennutzung und wie geht man damit um. Dir erstmal vielen Dank und schönen Abend nach Kreuzberg.
Hallo Björn.
Hallo.
Grüße dich, du bist 24, rufst aus Hannover an.
Genau.
Und hast den Vorschlag des Medienführerscheins. Der kommt ja immer wieder mal gerne. Kannst du das mal erläutern?
Ja, also in meiner Fallstellung nach ist das so eine Einstellung der Eltern, vielleicht unter psychologischer Einwirkung, also aus psychologischer Unterstützung, dass eben für Kinder angegeben wird, inwieweit die Medien konsumieren dürfen, die rüde Sprache enthalten, Gewalt enthalten, Sexualität enthalten, sodass die Eltern sagen können, mein Kind darf bis Punkt 5 Gewaltspiele spielen und gewalttätige Musiker und solche Geschichten und bis zwei sexuelle Inhalte konsumieren und solche Geschichten.
Wie bis zwei sexuelle Inhalte?
Ich hab mal so eine Fantasieskala genommen von 1 bis 10.
Ach so quasi so ein Zahlenlevel, dass man sagt wird, das ist grün, rot, blau, gelb.
Genau.
Alles klar.
Das ist eigentlich mein Vorschlag, weil ohne diesen Ausschuss würde es einfach nichts geben. Dann müssten die Kinder ihre Eltern darauf drängen, dieses Ding auszufüllen.
Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich, dass jeder, der in irgendeiner Form Medien konsumiert, also ein Laden geht, sowas kauft, so eine Berechtigungskarte irgendwie rausgeben muss, oder wie?
Bei den Erwachsenen kann man das ja dann nicht mehr so wirklich kontrollieren.
Könnte man mit dem Schülerausweis oder der Monatskarte koppeln, irgend sowas, irgendeine Idee schwebt dir vor, oder?
Ja, ganz genau.
Und dann ist da hinten grüner, blauer oder gelber Punkt drauf und der, der es verkauft, sagt dann, zeig ich mal deine Schnipselkarte da.
Genau.
Und anhand derer wird dann entschieden, ob das freigegeben wird oder nicht. Kann man doch aber auch sein lassen, wenn man sich einfach so einen Schülerausweis zeigen lässt, da steht ein Geburtstag drauf.
Ja, aber diese Altersfeigabe differenziert nicht so gut, wie ich finde, wie diese Tabelle.
Ich glaube, ich verstehe ungefähr, worauf du hinauswirst und zwar wieder auf das Thema, dass sich Eltern ja mit ihren Kindern und mit den Inhalten beschäftigen müssen. Aber so ein Medienführerschein, wie du ihn gerade beschreibst, ist glaube ich von den meisten Kindern, die sowohl technikversiert sind als wahrscheinlich total einfach zu kopieren. Und B würde es den Eltern glaube ich so ein bisschen wieder die Verantwortung aus der Hand nehmen zu sagen, so Kind, ich nehme dich jetzt an die Hand und ich gehe mit dir in die Videothek oder in den Buchladen etc. und kaufe mit dir das Spiel.
Gut, aber das machen die ja in der Praxis eh nicht. Also insofern wäre es zumindest vielleicht doch ein erster Ansatz, dass die Eltern wenigstens sich einmal Gedanken machen, was soll man Kind eigentlich sehen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass Eltern, die das was ich gerade beschrieben habe sowieso keinen Bock drauf haben, dann Bock drauf haben sich so ein Formular vielleicht auszufüllen, sich gezielt Gedanken darüber zu machen und das auszufüllen. Die werden das dann einfach so, ich sag jetzt mal, frei Schnauze ausfüllen. So, muss ja schnell fertig werden und mein Kind drängt hier gerade, weil es wäre das, weiß ich, Doom 3.
Mama, ich brauch hier noch meinen Ausweis, ich will mir noch ein Ballerspiel holen, und dann hast du noch irgendwie fünf Marke, ich brauch Kondome. Was, Kondome?
Das wär das Problem an der Sache, aber das ist dann wieder eine Sache der Verwirklichung.
Wo kann denn angesetzt werden? Wir hatten schon bei der Medienkompetenz von Lehrern, da waren wir schon, dass viele Lehrer überhaupt nicht bereit sind, sich mit solchen Dingen auseinanderzusetzen. Sie müssen sich ja nicht zocken, aber wenigstens wissen, worum es geht. Mit der Musik zu beschäftigen, überhaupt sich mit der Lebenswirklichkeit ihrer Schüler zu beschäftigen. Dass die Eltern oft zu faul sind oder zu beschäftigt sind, um sich damit zu beschäftigen, was ihre Sprösslinge da machen. Dass man da doch irgendwo anfangen müsste. Also das Problem der Frage, wer ist dafür eigentlich verantwortlich? Wer muss sich darum kümmern? Muss man nicht eigentlich da ansetzen?
Ja, das müsste bei den Lehrern dann aber schon Teil des Studiums sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut zu verwirklichen ist. Da müsste man ja Professoren ein Killerspiel unterrichten, in Anführungszeichen.
Aber wie ist denn das im Studium heute? Weiß das jemand?
Also ich bin ja Pädagogik- oder Erziehungswissenschafts-Student und ich kenne auch so ein paar Lehrämter. Und mittlerweile gibt es da schon die Tendenzen einer Umstrukturierung, dass das Schulsystem an sich nicht mehr auf Frontalunterricht basieren sollte, sondern auf dieser Kompetenzvermittlung, wo halt eine Teil Medienkompetenz wäre. Und da ist ganz klar ein Problem, warum das auch noch nicht irgendwie so Schlag auf Schlag umgesetzt werden konnte, auch nach PISA zum Beispiel nicht, dass es halt noch keine Lehrer gab, die genau auf solche Unterrichtsformen ausgebildet waren. Weil bisher, wenn ich mir so das Lehramtsstudium angeguckt habe, war halt sehr wenig Pädagogik dabei. Aber ich glaube, das wird sich in Zukunft ändern.
Na, wollen wir auf jeden Fall hoffen. Björn, danke für deinen Anruf und schönen Abend nach Hannover. No, ebenfalls. Bevor wir hier einen Stecker ziehen, kriegt Sebastian aus Neukölln das Schlusswort. Hallo Sebastian. Hallo. Du hast sehr lange gewartet, auch dir vielen Dank für die Geduld.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, das Schlusswort ist deins.
Okay, prima. Also ich wollte jetzt zum Ende nicht mehr resignativ wirken, aber ich denke, dass mit dem Einführen des Internets hier in Deutschland generell solchen Problematiken eigentlich Tür und Tor irgendwie geöffnet wurden. Also da ist einfach mal wirklich alles möglich. Und egal, wie man es regulieren will oder nicht, sobald der Staat, finde ich, einfach die kompetenten Leute einfach nicht inne hat, die sich mit solchen Thematiken auskennen, was das Technische angeht, dann hinkt man immer hinterher. Und ich denke auch, dass das hauptsächlich wirklich eine Erziehungsfrage ist. Also man muss mit dieser Problematik leben und man muss die Problematik einfach akzeptieren, dass es solche Sachen gibt. Man muss einfach seine Kinder erziehen, wie sie später damit umgehen werden, weil wegkriegen tut man sie einfach wirklich nicht.
Na und man muss sich selber in seinem bestehenden Weltbild immer mal wieder neu justieren und neu korrigieren und sich auf neue Sachen einlassen.
Das stimmt. Also ich denke auch zum Beispiel Pornografie, zum Beispiel, was ja glaube ich noch gar nicht angesprochen ist. Also jeder Mensch, der irgendwie Zugang zum Web über einen Browser hat, kann damals sogar noch über Google Sachen suchen, die natürlich jetzt rausgenommen wurden. Aber selbst auf Indexseiten von ganz normalen Webseiten sind eindeutige Hardcore-Pornografische Bilder zu sehen für die Jugendlichen. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Man kann dieses Ding einfach, das geht nicht mehr rückgängig zu machen.
Das wird auf jeden Fall, denke ich, wieder ein Thema werden und damit verbunden auch die Geschlechterbilder, die da transportiert werden.
Aber auch das ist ein anderer Topf.
Absolut, ja klar. Aber betrifft man auch wieder den Jugendmedienschutz und da können wir dann eventuell so ein bisschen von der Gewaltdebatte wegkommen. Aber ich denke, Pornografie wird wieder ein Thema werden. Wie damals bei der Videowelle eigentlich auch.
Genau, also es war schon mit der Jugend immer ein Problem. Damals war es, als ich jung war, also also...
Ja, du bist 26 komm.
Jugendlich war, da war es das Problem, zum Beispiel, wie beschafft man sich Alkohol. Sobald es irgendwelche zwischenmenschlichen Beziehungen gibt und man hat Bekanntschaften, dann wird es gekauft von jemandem, der es darf. Also, man kommt da immer ran, egal wie. Und gerade, wie auch schon gesagt wurde, dass einfach mal die Kids heutzutage so technisch versiert werden, dass sie den Eltern des blauen Himmels erzählen können. Und man kann einfach da nichts machen.
Na doch, man kann genau da ansetzen.
Inwiefern? Die Eltern bilden?
Ja, definitiv.
Ja, gut, das wäre auf jeden Fall eine Sache, die...
Also ich muss einfach, ich muss als Vater oder Mutter einfach in der Lage sein, rauszufinden, was auf dem Rechner meines Kindes ist. Also das muss ich einfach können. Wenn ich das nicht kann, muss ich dieses Wissen nachholen.
Genau, das stimmt. Aber dafür ist auf jeden Fall das Interesse der Eltern notwendig.
Ja, aber das setzt sich mal voraus, wenn ich Kinder habe.
Ich glaube, in dem Moment, wo sich die Eltern wirklich auch für die Kinder interessieren und mit den Kindern gemeinsam am PC sitzen, ist es vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr nötig, dass die Eltern die Kinder hinterherschnüffeln, was sie auf dem PC haben. Sondern wenn einfach dieses Vertrauen da ist, dass man sich auch Sachen gemeinsam angucken kann oder dass die Kinder von sich aus bestimmte Sachen vielleicht nicht ansehen, dann wäre das natürlich noch besser, als dass die Eltern quasi den Kindern hinterherschnüffeln müssen und schauen, dass die da nichts verboten ist, in Anführungszeichen angucken.
Genau, das sehe ich genauso. Ich würde auch als Elternteil, wenn ich mal Kinder haben sollte, einfach aus Respekt vor meinem Kind nicht auf die Idee kommen, eigentlich auszuspionieren, was der da macht.
Also ich wollte jetzt auch nicht, dass Eltern ihren Kindern hinterherschnüffeln, aber sie sollten in etwa auf dem Level der Kinder einfach sein und sich auch mit Computern auskennen und auch wissen, was einfach gerade los ist.
Anstatt zu sagen, Eltern, Lehrer, auch große Brüder oder Schwestern sind auch angesprochen, genauso wie Cousins und Neffen und Nichten und wer auch immer da ist oder Kumpels, anstatt zu sagen, finde ich scheiße, finde ich doof, lieber mal fragen, was ist denn das, erklär mir das mal, lass mich mal reingucken.
Genau, aber ich habe die Befürchtung, dass dieses Interesse wirklich zurückgeht. Also wenn man sich mal anguckt, was gerade auch hier, ich sag mal in der Köln, was man da so trifft in der U-Bahn, also es ist schon wirklich komisch. Also man zweifelt schon wirklich an so ein paar Sachen. Hm, was wachsen da für Generationen ran? Also es ist wirklich komisch.
Dann sieh zu, dass du dich um deine eigenen Kinder kümmerst.
Ja, natürlich. Eine Sache wollte ich gerne noch sagen. Ich hab das auch schon gepostet, dass ich so ein bisschen vermisst habe, gerade wenn die Leute oder die Jugendlichen, die so Ego-Shooter und so weiter spielen, auch in der Sendung jetzt schieben die immer so ein bisschen diese Strategieproblematik.
Ach, du bist der Bademeister. Der Bademeister aus dem Fritz-Board, da ist er.
Na ja, dann brauch ich ja nicht sagen. Also für die, die es noch nicht gelesen haben, ich finde schon, dass diese Taktik das immer versucht so ein bisschen abzumindern. Also ich finde, man kann es nicht wirklich auf Taktik schieben. Es bleibt dabei einfach, egal welchen Weg es nun nimmt, ob Taktik oder einfach nur so.
Prinzipiell, also du hast Recht natürlich, wenn du sagst, ob ich jetzt taktisch oder quasi nur, um quasi den Abzug zu ziehen, in ein Computerspiel schieße. Der Vorgang bleibt derselbe. Aber Untersuchungen von Psychologen haben durchaus ergeben, dass es etwas anderes ist, wenn man selber spielt oder wenn man daneben steht und zuguckt. Und die Art und Weise, wie du es selber rezipierst, ist durchaus eine andere. Ob du siehst oder ob du es selber machst. Und es gibt durchaus Studien, die sagen, dass das taktische Denken, also dieses, welchen Schritt mache ich nach dem anderen? Ich bin selber kein Zocker, ich saß eben so wie es ist. Welchen Schritt gehe ich jetzt vor dem anderen? Welche Strategie habe ich, welchen Plan mache ich? Wesentlich anspruchsvoller fürs Hirn ist und wesentlich andere Dinge in deinem Hirn beansprucht, als nur zu sagen, Feuer, Dauerfeuer, Knopf drücken, fertig.
Also das sind zwei unterschiedliche Geschichten.
Ja genau, genau.
Also ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, ich habe Hitman gespielt, wo ich sage, da kommt es eher auf Taktik an. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich auch Post-Hit gespielt. Bei mir ist der Effekt einfach mal, die Quintessenz ist, ich muss jemanden töten.
Die Quintessenz bleibt natürlich dieselbe, die Mission, die du hast, aber du beschäftigst deinen Kopf mit anderen Dingen. Du stellst dich halt jetzt nicht hin und sagst, du willst sie alle platt machen, sondern du willst da vorrangig eine Aufgabe lösen, einen Rätsel lösen. Aber auch das führt zu weit, da könnt ihr gerne weitermachen im Fritz-Board unter fritz.de. Da wird Sebastian gerne mit euch weiterdiskutieren. Interessante These, weil uns läuft die Zeit weg. Und jetzt kommt Martin Peters drauf mit dem Night Flight. Chaosradio 125 ist damit zu Ende. Danke an Frank, danke Annett, danke an Thorsten. Sehr kontroverses Thema, kann man viel darüber diskutieren. Das werden wir wahrscheinlich auch noch weiterhin machen. Aber nicht mehr jetzt, weil jetzt ist es kurz vor eins. Wir sagen Danke fürs Zuhören. Mehr unter ccc.de. Da gibt es demnächst dann einen Podcast dazu.
Gibt's auch, genau. Und wenn ihr noch Sachen habt, die ihr uns mitteilen möchtet, dann Chaosradio at ccc.de.
Genau. Und ansonsten fritz.de. Immer schön fritz hören, lass dich nicht ärgern. Bis denn.
Tschüss, gute Nacht.